WILL COME TO ORDER A GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COMMUNITY NUMBERS SEEM TO
PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. OF WE ARE STILL MANY
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL TO SOSINA FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS. TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LYNC APPEARANCE TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE TEARS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. BUT TODAY SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. AS HAS BEEN DETERMINED
LEAD WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH WITNESS AND
THERE IS NO RESERVING TIME FOR
OTHER WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION. AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. THE FOR THESE
WITNESSES WILL BE A LIMIT OF
TEN MINUTES FOR SUPPORT AND TEN
MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION IN WILL
TAKE THOSE SEPARATELY. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOM SIX AT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW AS WELL TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AGAIN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
FIVE SIX ZERO TWO ZERO FIVE
FIVE SIX ZERO. TWO ZERO FIVE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO TALK CURRENT SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND- COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
REMOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. FOUR
SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION.
PURPOSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN SOMETIMES BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOU
MY NUMBER AT THAT TIME HE WILL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE.
TO BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT
OUR HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON
CONSENT. THOSE BILLS ARE AB
THREE SIXTEEN A. B. FOR. ZERO
FOUR AND AB FIVE SIXTY FIVE
WITH BEFORE WE GO. TO THE
AGENDA LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
SENATOR COURTESY THE TO THE
HERE SENATOR CHOI BOGUE. THE
TROUBLE CARE CENTERED ALSO HERE
WITH US ARE HERE SENATOR LEHRER
HERE THEY'RE HERE IN CENTER
NEWMAN HERE. NEWMAN HERE WE
HAVE A CAR THANK YOU M. WE WILL
THEN- MOVE BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
CONSENT MOVE THE CONSENT AGENDA
THANK YOU- MOTION BY LAYERED.
AGAIN THOSE THREE BILLS OR AB
THREE SIXTEEN MAYBE FOUR OR
FOUR MAYBE FIVE SIXTY FIVE- WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND- THAT ARE
PROTESTING I PROTESTED BY THE
CHORE BOOK. THE TROUBLE GUY
WRESTLE HI THE DRESS I LAYER BY.
FLARED I NEWMAN. NEWMAN NINE.
THANK YOU- CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT ON THE UNANIMOUS WILL.
WELCOME BACK THE PHONE NUMBER
ONE THIS IS A ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIVE THIRTY NINE- THE AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AND- IF
YOU IF YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU. FOR A PROJECT WE WANT TO
SEND THE LETTER TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY- I WORKED IN
THE BUILDING IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
WHEN YOUR DAD WAS ELECTED.
ACTUALLY WORKED ON AC AC A
SIXTEEN IN THE- EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR SESSION WHICH SHE
WOULD PROBABLY VOTED ON THAT'S
THE ONE THAT ACTUALLY PUT
CALPERS INVESTMENT SYSTEM ON
PRUDENT EXPERT STANDARD WHICH
IS CENTRAL TO THE BILL RELEVANT
TO THE BILL TODAY FIVE ZERO THE
BALLOT ARGUMENT ON PROP TWENTY
ONE- THAT YEAR I WAS SENT BY
DECEMBER THE WHARTON SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS TO WORK ON PENSION
ISSUES. AND BEFORE I LEFT I
WORKED ON ABOUT SIXTEEN BILLS
OVER FOUR YEARS ON PENSIONS
SOLD IN ORDER TO BE IN YOUR
COMPANY TODAY I HAVEN'T BEEN
HERE WHAT'S YOUR FATHER'S
WEALTH WELCOME TO THE- SO I'M
HERE TO READ WAS. A FIVE THIRTY
NINE. WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT BOARD
TO ESTABLISH PRUDENT AND
FRAZIER REALLY RESPONSIBLE
POLICIES. TO PROCURE CONTRACTS
WITH EXTERNAL INVESTMENT
MANAGERS AND ADVISORS. THIS. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR WHEN PROP
TWENTY ONE WAS PASSED THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO KIND OF EQUIPPED OF
THE PENSION SYSTEMS WHICH HAVE
THIS OBLIGATION TO INVEST FUNDS
PRUDENTLY TO SUPPORT A DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION IN CALIFORNIA
TO DEAL WITH WHAT WAS IN A VERY
CHANGE IN- ENVIRONMENT OF
INVESTMENTS THAT'S A PROP
TWENTY ONE DID THAT THERE IS A
NEED IN THE PENSION SYSTEMS.
SUBJECT TO THE PRUDENT EXPERT
RULE PROP TWENTY ONE THE
PRUDENT EXPERT STANDARD. TO RUN
THEIR INVESTMENT PROGRAMS IN A
SAFE AND PUT AWAY BUT NONE THE
LESS TO MAXIMIZE RETURNS THE
SYSTEM FOR THE DELIVERY
BENEFITS BOTH PENSION BENEFIT
ANY OTHER BENEFITS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. AND THIS HAS
REQUIRED OVERTIME THE EVOLUTION
OF LONG THIS. HAS BEEN SUBJECT
TO PRUDENT STANDARDS INCREASE
THE FLEXIBILITY THE PRINCE'S
SISTERS TO JUDGE WHAT THEY'RE
UP AGAINST. AND FIND THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENT VEHICLES
THIS BILL- RESPOND TO THE FACT
THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF
HIRING OUTSIDE TALENT. YOU SEE
SORT OF A CUMBERSOME ARE OF
PREPROCESSOR JIM IMPLIES A
STATE LAW. HINDERS THE ABILITY
OF CAL STIRRERS TO FIND OUT
STATE INVESTMENT TALENT THE
VERTIGO SHE ADDED TO TERMS THAT
DON'T RIP OFF THE SYSTEM. TO
BRING THAT TALENT TO BEAR A
SPECIALIZED INVESTMENTS AND
THEREFORE SUPPORT THE OVERALL
YIELD OF THE STATUS RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. SO A BILL LIKE THIS AS
LONG AS IT HAS SAFEGUARDS AS
INDEED I BELIEVE IT DOES.
ACTUALLY IS GOOD TO LONG TERM
HEALTH OF THE CRITICISMS AND
THEY'RE BILLION PRESENTER
PROMISES FOR PERFORM THEIR
PROMISES- THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
CALPERS STAFF TO CAPTURE VESTED
OPPORTUNITIES. NEGOTIATE LOWER
FEES AND BETTER TERMS AS EIGHT
SIX RESPONSIBILITY FOR NOT FOR
THE WHOLE PORTFOLIO. BUT FIRST
PROVIDERS WERE THERE'S
INVESTMENT SO THEY WOULD LIKE
TO. PURSUE AND LEARN ABOUT. OF
CALPERS PRESIDENT RETIREMENT OR
FOR USE IN THERE ARE PEOPLE
SERVICE. BUT THAT. CRISIS CAN
BE SLOW. HINDER THEIR ABILITY
TO TAKE PLACE TAKE A VENTURE
MARKETPLACE OPPORTUNITIES- AB
FIVE THIRD I WILL REQUIRE A NEW
CONTRACT TO PROCESS. HELLO TO
ENGAGE WITH INVESTMENT MANAGERS
ADVISORS IT IS TO BE
ESTABLISHED BY A BORDER
INCLUDES LEADERS FROM OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES. AND WOULD BE
COMPELLED BY FIDUCIARY DUTY
WHICH IS THE OLD PROP TWENTY
ONE BUT ALSO STANDARDS IN
STATUTE THE DOCTOR WHAT THAT
COME THROUGH FOR PROVISION. OF
COMPELLED WHAT FUTURE DO YOU
CHOOSE THE BEST PERFORMERS. TO
BRUCE AGREES FOR TERMS OF LOS
COST. IN FOLLOWING THIS DUTY
INVEST FOR CONTRACTS OR SERVICE
TRANSIENT AND TOTAL CONTROLS.
AND SEPARATE TO REVIEWED BY
OUTSIDE PARTIES WHICH INCLUDES
BOTH THE- CONTRA TRACKS WITH
THE PUBLIC APPLY REPRESENTS A
DISCLOSES CONTRACT TERMS
ALREADY. WELL AN INTERNAL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVE
CHECK ON POTENTIAL ABUSE OF
PROCESS. BUT ALSO THE STATE
AUDITOR OF STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WILL CHECK RECEIPTS. AND
THE STATE AUDITOR WILL HAVE A
OVERVIEW FUNCTION. SO IT'S KIND
RELIES ON THESE EXISTING
SYSTEMS A CALIFORNIA LAW-
GREATER FLEXIBILITY PROCURING
NEW INVESTED MEASURES OF VISORS
WILL IMPROVE CULTURES ABILITY
TO MEET ITS PERFORMANCE
OBJECTIVES. BY TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF FEDERAL MARKET DYNAMICS
MAXIMIZING GAINS AND MINIMIZING
LOSSES. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
JOHNSON MARTINEZ WAY DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS A CAL
STIRS. TO OFFER TESTIMONY ON
THE IMPORTANCE AND BENEFITS OF
THIS BILL- TO CALPERS AND ITS
MEMBERS. THANK THANK YOU SO
MOVE OVER- IN THE WE WILL GO
AHEAD. TO COMPLETE SUPPORT
WITNESSES THE UNDERSTAND WERE
HEARD- CORRECTLY JOCELYN.
MARTINEZ WAIT. YES RIGHT IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS STORY SALEN
MARTINEZ WEIGHED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM THE SPONSORS
OF AB FIVE THIRTY NINE THIS
BILL SUPPORTS OUR INVESTMENT
STRATEGY CALLED THE CHARACTERS
COLLABORATE MODEL TO REDUCE
COST CONTROL RISKS AN INCREASE
RETURNED BY MANAGING MORE
ASSETS INTERNALLY AND
LEVERAGING EXTERNAL
PARTNERSHIPS. WITHIN THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE WE COMPETE WITH
LARGER AND MORE AGILE FUNDS FOR
INVESTMENT THE CAPTURE EXTERNAL
MANAGERS THAT CAN WORK WITH
THEIR PICK OF INVESTORS AS SUCH
THEY DO NOT WISH TO ENGAGE IN
OUR CURRENT CONTRACTING PROCESS
WHICH CAN TAKE WELL OVER A YEAR
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES CAN SHIFT
AND DISAPPEAR. WHAT A PROCESS
DEVELOPED UNDER THIS BILL YOUR
BOARD POLICY WITH STRONG
OVERSIGHT FROM OUR BOARD AND
THEIR FIDUCIARY DUTY IN
INTERNAL SAFEGUARDS WE COULD
ALLEVIATE BOTTLENECKS THERE IS
NO INTENTION TO REMOVE THE
CHECKS. AND BALANCES NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS. ATION OF THE
PLAYER. FOR STATE HER. AT NEW
SERIES AS YOU FUND IN TRY.
CONTRACT FOR INVESTMENT
MANAGERS AND ADVISORS MUST BE
CONSIDERED CRITICAL BENEFIT OF
OUR MEMBERS. OTHERWISE WE COULD
BE SUBJECT TO SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES. THIS ALONG WITH
INTERNALCONTROLS INCLUDING
HAVING LEADERS OF VARIOUS
CONTROL AGENCIES ON OUR BOARD%
WILL GUIDE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY NINE
TO HELP CHARACTERS MINIMIZE
LOSSES THE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES. AND MAXIMIZE.
GAINS THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE
WILL NOW ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE. C. KNOWN COME
FORWARD- WE WILL CHECK- THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE. C. NONE-
WE WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE OPERATOR
MODERATOR- WOULD YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE AND PLEASE LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER OF SPEAKERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE TO
INTHE Q. AND MINE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH. ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND MOVING
ON COMBINED. ONE SIXTEEN ONE
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE. ONE ONE SIXTEEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. STE MY COMMENT IS TO
SUPPORT A DISTRICT SIX OKAY AT
THAT TIME MINUTES THE DISCUSSED
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND PRESS THE
ONE ZERO AT THAT TIME. THANK
YOU YOU'RE WELCOME. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY NINE
OKAY SIR THANK YOU MODERATOR IN
OVER THERE SO I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S A ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE OR
ON YOUR SIDE IF IT'S POSSIBLE
FOR THE VOLUME TO COME UP JUST
A LITTLE BIT- THERE'S A LITTLE
AND HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TROUBLE HEARING YOU THANK YOU-
WE WILL. NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
OCEAN THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES OR ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHICH SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB FIVE THIRTY NINE IF SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. UNSEEN
NONE. I WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. I'M NOT SURE CLEAR THERE
IT IS THE NOBODY'S HERE TO
SPEAK ON AB FIVE THIRTY NINE IN
OPPOSITION WELCOME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR AND ASK YOU TO QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ONLY BE FIVE THIRTY NINE AGAIN-
LET US KNOW THE IN THE NUMBER
OF SPEAKERS. AND THANK YOU MR
CARE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE THIRTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU WOULDN'T COME BACK TO A
COMMITTEE MEMBER SAYS FOR THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ON
THIS BILL- SEE NONE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE-
THAT WOULD BE THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD TIME TO DO IT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I APPRECIATE THAT
SERVES AT THIS BILL I. REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON AB. FIVE THIRTY
NINE THREE THINK USER MOTION-
BY NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
NOTICE- AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL OUT. IF TO AVOID
ANY CONFUSION. A THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY BY
PROTESTS THE AYE BUT CHAU BOKE.
SOCIABLE GUY WRESTLE THE
RUSSELL I LAYERED. I NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT NEWMAN I- THAT THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME OKAY THANK YOU-
WE ARE GOING TO. TAKE AN ITEM
OUT OF ORDER BY PRIOR.
AGREEMENT OR UNDERSTANDING AND-
THAT WOULD PUT US- TEMPORARILY
OUT OF ORDER AT LEAST WITH-
WITH AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN NEXUS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACE BILL AND-
HE WERE. WELCOME TO COME
FORWARD AND PRESENT THE SINS
ARE SANITIZED. HI AND THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
TERMINATING THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OF EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
DEPENDENTS DURING A STRIKE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MOVE OVER A-
WE HAVE AS A LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS JANET SO MELANIE GOOD
RESUMES ARE CORRECT- MS GILLIES
HILL IF YOU'RE HERE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PROCEED. THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JENNIFER MOJICA LOUISIANA
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
MEMBERS OF ASKED ME THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE ALONG WITH MANY OF
OUR AFFILIATES AND CENTRAL
LABOR COUNCILS ACROSS THE
STATE. WHO BELIEVE THAT WITH
HOLDING AN EMPLOYEES HEALTH
CARE WHILE I'M STRAIGHT IS
APPALLING AND UNLAWFUL. THE
COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
DEMONSTRATED UNMISTAKABLY THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS EVERYONE.
THERE SHOULD NEVER BE ANY
INCENTIVE TO EACH D. JACK
PEOPLE FROM THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES. SHE DAMAGE TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND TO THE
ENTIRE POPULATION CAN BE
DISASTROUS. ALLOWING EMPLOYERS
TO WEAPONIZE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SIMPLY TO GAIN AN
ADVANTAGE IN LABOR NEGOTIATIONS
IT'S NOT ONLY INCREDIBLY UNFAIR
THAT DANGEROUS TO OUR ENTIRE
SOCIETY. THE FACT THAT THERE IS
NO EXISTING STATUTORY
PROHIBITION AGAINST THIS. PUT
SIMPLY IS AT AN UNFAIR
DISADVANTAGE AND EVEN THE
THREAT OF SUCH ACTION BY AN
EMPLOYER STARTS TO WEAPONIZE
HEALTHCARE AND THE RETENTION OF
BENEFITS. THIS UNFAIR SCARE
TACTIC SHOULD NEVER BE USED TO
DISSUADE AN EMPLOYEE FROM THE
EXERCISE OF THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW. LEADERS MUST BE
PROHIBITED FROM CONTINUING TO
BENEFIT FROM THAT THE
CREATURE'S BEHAVIOR. THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN IS AN IPORTANT STEP
FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT ALL
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS CAN STILL
RECEIVE INSURANCE DESPITE
MAKING THE DIFFICULT DECISION
TO GO ON STRIKE. I WOULD THINK
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS A
FAMILY MAN GRAY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL TO
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS. AND- YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
AND UNDERSTAND WE ALSO OF-
MICHAEL THE BOND. MICHAEL'S
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS WERE
GOING TO TESTIFY BEFORE
TESTIFYING MAY PROCEED PLEASE.
YES THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MICHAEL BONTA I AM THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
ATHLETES THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
REPRESENTED SERVICE WORKERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE JANITORS
GROUNDSKEEPERS CAFETERIA
WORKERS AND MEDICAL ASSISTANCE.
YOU THE STATE LEGISLATIVE GAVE
US THE RIGHT TO STRIKE. AND
WHEN WE THE WORKERS DESPITE TO
EXERCISE THAT RIGHT WE DO SO
AFTER WHEN ALL OTHER OPTIONS.
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO ON STRIKE WE
SACRIFICE. WE LOSE OUR PAY WE
MAKE THE SACRIFICE IN THE HOPE
WE CAN IMPROVE OUR LIVES AND
THAT OF OUR FAMILIES. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
USING MANAGING OUR LIFESAVING
TREATMENT AS A WEAPON AGAINST
EXERCISING THAT RIGHT. FOR US
WE EXPERIENCED A RECENT THREAT
AT UC SANTA CRUZ WHEN THEY
INFORMED US THAT IF WE REMAIN
ON STRIKE THAT WE WILL LOSE OUR
FAMILY'S HEALTH COVERAGE. THIS
OCCURRED AFTER YOU SEE NEW A
STRIKE LEADERS SON WAS BATTLING
BRAIN CANCER. WE THANK ASSEMBLY
WEARING GRAY FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS BILL WHICH HELP CLARIFY
THAT THE WEAPONS EDUCATION
AGAINST HEALTH CARE IS NOT
PERMITTED IN THE STATE. WE
ACCESS FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU WHO NOW
MOVES TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM ARE
THERE- ANY PERSONS IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN OF SO PLEASE
COMPORT. I WILL CHECK THE
OVERFLOW ROOM SEEN NONE THERE
WILL MOVE TO. THE
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IN ASK
YOU TO PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN AT THIS TIME AND
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE
SEVEN PARTIES. IN THE- COMMENT
QUEUE. THANK YOU NUMBER IS
GOING. AND MINE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ACTUALLY HAD COMMENT FOR A
FACTORY NINE BUT YOU'LL HAVE
JOHN. IT IS IT OKAY TO TAKE
FIVE THIRTY NINE AT THIS TIME
NO NO IT OKAY THANKS SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU WHAT YOU WANT ME TO
GIVE TIME FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY PUSH THE BUTTONS TO
GET INTO TIMELY YOU CAN'T JUST.
ASK US TO DO IT WE DO IT AND
THEN YOU MOVE ON WE UNDERSTAND
YOUR POSITION ANYWAY SO HAVE
YOU ACCOMPLISH YOUR PURPOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN MODERN
YOU CAN GO ON TO THE NEXT TO.
THE NEXT ONE PLEASE THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS THIS
IS SETH BROWN BOTH SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN NAME IS MOLLY FIND
WHAT YOU W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARGAINING
CHAIR MEMBERS CATHOLICATE OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB CUTE THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS- THIS IS FRANCISCO THAT
SEE I'M I'M PRO MAR UC.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA- PHYSICAL FACILITIES
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND THIRTY
YEARS. I'M WITH THE UNION
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE AND I
SUPPORT. BILL AB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. R. IF THAT'S ALL YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO SAY ON THIS LINE SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING.
THIS IS JUST A SUPPORT LINE.
FIVE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DONNA MCANALLY ROLLING ON
THE SCREEN- AT PARNASSUS AND I
AM SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THANK
YOU. NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS SIKI WHATEVER- FEDERAL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO THREE SEVEN. NINE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CREDIT
MORRELL AND I WANT TO START THE
YEAR BEFORE THE END AT UCSB
CAMPUS AND I'M SUPPORT THE BILL.
NINE ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CALLED QUERY
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
NINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ERICA DONNA YOUR DUTY
CAN BE FOUND AT YOU SEE THERE
MEDICAL CENTER YES I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS EIGHTY NINE A
SENIOR AT UC MEDICAL THANK IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTY TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. MY ONE OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ROSE ZERO THAT
AGAIN I AM SENIOR BECAUSE- AND
HOW THAT BERKELEY NIGHTS OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY IS IRIS TELL I
WORK YOU SEE MET CENTER THANK
YOU FOR. AND BEING HERE FOR AT-
I AM SUPPORT OF THIS. THANK YOU.
MY ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. NINE ONE OF
FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ANOTHER AVERAGES SIX
FIFTY SEVEN- OF THE SPEAKING ON
THAT WELL OKAY THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY SO YOUR LINE IS UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET OUT. MY
NAME IS CAMERA BURKE I AM EIGHT
THE- I WORK FOR YOU YEAH I
CAN'T. AND I AM IN SUPPORT- THE
BILL THAT TWO THIRTY. MY ONE
THREE YOUR LONG IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. THE GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED
MEMBERS PATRICK WHELAN ELSE
WILL SMITH TO SEE A THAT
THERE'S THAT YOU SHOULD
CALIFORNIA UNITED HEALTHCARE.
DO THEIR- WE US A TO LATE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THIRTY SO THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER AND AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU- WE ARE WE'RE IN
THE LEAD UP WITNESS ON BILL'S
WE WILL ASK CITY WHEN IN
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WAS TO STAY
OF THIS OFF. TO AB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN. I'VE SEEN NONE. I WILL
CHECK FOR ROOM WE HAVE NO WHEN
THE THERE. WILL BACK TOMORROW.
MODERN Q. A UP A TO A TWO SO
PLEASE US KNOW THE NEW WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER. AND LADIES
AND IF YOU WISH TO STAY AN UP.
OF AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY WE HAVE ONE
PARTY. IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME AND ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
MOTOR
YOU SEE WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS CUTER WE DO OKAY WE DO
BLIND ONE TWENTY YOUR LONG AND
OPEN GO AHEAD. MEMBERS THIS IS
KILLING WITH THE CALIBER SPACE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND I.
WITH STATED LETTER IN L. A. YOU.
AND THERE ENOUGH. ONE WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER PARTY THAT JUST
JOIN. ONE MOMENT WHILE YOU
GATHER THE LINE NUMBER. THANK
YOU.
SB JUST A BRIEF MOMENT
LONGER. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL SHARE HOBBLING THEY
HAVE OF THE UNIVERSE OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. YEAH. NO FURTHER IN QUEUE
AT THI TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR PREPARE THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OF CENTER DRAWS A
YES OR TO THANK AUTHOR FOR THIS
AND- WHEN APPROPRIATE THE MOVE
MOVE THE- HAVING. AT UNIVERSITY
AT SOME OF THE CAMPUSES WHEN
ALL THESE WORKERS WERE REALLY
FORCED TO GO OUT ON STRIKE I
FOUND IT QUITE APPALLING THAT
THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR HEALTH
CARE ALL WHILE THEY DID THAT
AND- SO I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS MAKING THAT
CHANGE- AND FOR THE MOST PART
THESE WOULD WORKERS. WHO COULD
NOT AFFORD. BOMBED GOING TO THE
DAY ON THEIR OWN WITH HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE ALL WORK WHO'D
THIS THAT SOMETIMES DON'T GET
THE APPLE AT THAT THE BUT THEY
KEEP THE CAMPUSES ARE GOING SO
WHY AM I SO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS AND I WISH THIS WAS THE
LAW OF THE LAND AND SO- SO THAT
NO WORKING MAN OR WOMAN WOULD
EVER FEEL THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO LOSE THEIR HEALTHCARE ALL
WHEN THEY MAKE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND RARE DECISION TO
GO OUT ON STRIKE SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THINK THE SOONER
ANYBODY- ON TRUMP'S COMMENTS ON
BILL. SEIGNER OF COMPACT THE
AUTHOR YOU CLOSER YOU LIFE.
BAKER IS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIR
DRAWS FOR YOUR CAR COMMENTS. AS
SOME WHO LIVES WITH- TO TIE ONE
FROM IMMEDIATE I ALL TOO WELL
UNDERSTAND IMPACT ON HEALTHCARE
AND WHY- IT SHOULD NEVER BE
WEBER IN THE IN THE SECOND SO I
THINK THIS ISN'T STEP.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU SO OF OUR GREAT-
COME- ME A FISH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR ALSO MOVE AND WILL COME
BACK. FOR A ROLL CALL A CONSOLE
NOW. THE MOST IS. TO PASS THE
FOR BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE- A- CENTER COURTESY
HI BUT DOES HE A SHOWBOAT I
SHOVEL GUY THE RUSSELL. RUSSELL
I LAYERED HI THERE I NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT. NEWMAN HI. OKAY WE ARE A
TO WITH THE UNANIMOUS VOTE THE
BILL IS A BIGGEST AND THANK YOU.
ONE OF THOSE YEARS FOR THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- YOU MAY
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU. THANK. WITH ALL THE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS OUR PENSION SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING TO DO THEIR PART TO
PROTECT PENSIONS HELLO PUBLIC
SERVANTS. AB THREE SIX IS
INTENDED TO GIVE WORST PUBLIC
PENSIONS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE TO INVEST
AND MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S PENSION
FUNDS. THIS BILL CREATES A
PUBLIC RECORDS DISCLOSURE
STRUCTURE TO ALLOW PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEMS LIKE CALPERS TO
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE INVESTMENTS
IN THE PRIVATE LOW MARKET. IN
THE SAME WAY YOUR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION IS HELD
CONFIDENTIAL BY YOUR MORTGAGE
COMPANY THIS BILL SAYS THE PAY
STRUCTURE TO PROTECT. THE
BORROWER'S INFORMATION IF THE
PENSION SYSTEM WITH CAPITAL
THREE PRIVATE LOAN AGREEMENT.
WITH THIS BILL FOR THE PAY
STRUCTURE TO BRING THESE
INVESTMENTS IN HOUSE RATHER
THAN OUTSIDE FIRMS TO MANAGE
THESE LOANS. DISCLOSURE
STRUCTURE PROVIDES CERTAINTY
FOR POTENTIAL BORROWERS BY
BRINGING THIS WORK IN HOUSE
CALPERS CAN SAVE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. IN FEES
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PAY TO
OUTSIDE FIRMS THE BILL'S PRICE
RIGHT BILLS BETWEEN
CONFIDENTIALITY NECESSARY FOR
BORROWERS AND THE TRANSPARENCY
REQUIRED THE PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEM. I ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AGREE TO HELP PUT THEM INTO
PRINT GOING INTO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE THE CHECK
COMMITTEES WORKING WITH ME WITH
ME TODAY ARE DANNY BROWN
CALPERS LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIVISION CHIEF WHO THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND KRISTI PALMA
PROPOSING. THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU SOME IN WHO MOVED TO
LEAVE THE SOME WITNESSED IN
BROKE AT THE START. WELCOME A
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DANNY
BROWN- FROM CALPERS. ABOARD
INITIATION WHO ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. LET ME START BY
THINKING THE AUTHOR- FOR HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA AND ALSO ALSO WANT TO
THINK OF SENATOR CORTESE AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS- PRIVATE DEBT
TRANSACTIONS OR INVESTMENTS BY
THE PENSION FUND SERVING AS THE
LENDER TO A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
COMPANIES SEEKING CAPITAL. FOR
SUCH THINGS AS OPERATIONS OR
GROWTH. CURRENTLY THE FUND
MAKES THESE INVESTMENTS BY
PAYING OUTSIDE FUND MANAGERS TO
MANAGE TO THE TRANSACTIONS
HOWEVER WHEN CALPERS YOU USES
OUT SIDE OF FUND MANAGERS THEY
PAY UP TO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
EVERYONE BILLION DOLLARS
INVESTED. AB THREE EIGHTY SIX
CREATES A DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
THAT WILL ALLOW CALPERS TO
BRING SOME OF THIS MANAGEMENT
OF PRIVATE DEBT INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSE. AND SITTING ON THOSE
EXTERNAL MANAGER FEES- THIS
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE IS ALSO
MODELED AFTER CURRENT LAW.
THAT'LL FOR EXTERNAL MANAGER SO
WHAT REALLY ASKING FOR IS BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT EXTERNAL
MANAGERS HAVE TO OUR INTERNAL
STAFF. THIS WILL GIVE A
BORROWER'S EXPECTATIONS WHEN
THEY COME TO HELP THE SAME
EXPECTATIONS THEY HAVE AN
EXTERNAL MARKET WHEN THEY COME
TO CALPERS. AND THIS WILL ALSO
ALLOW US TO ENTER THIS MARKET
COMPETITIVELY AT THE- AT THE
SCALE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE A
SENSE. SO CALPERS AGREES WITH
LEGITIMATE INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC IN KNOWING HOW PUBLIC
MONIES ARE INVESTED AS WELL AS
THE OBLIGATION TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO AN INFORMATION REQUEST. AND
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSED
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS-
BALLOTS EXIT EXISTING MARKET
EXPECTATIONS WITH OF THE NEED
FOR TRANSPARENCY FOR CALPERS
INVESTMENTS AND SO WITHOUT A
DOUBT FOR YOUR I. BOATS. OKAY
THE FIGURES RON. BONJEAN AND WE
WILL. ALSO COLIN CHRISTIE BOMA.
AS A SUPPORT WITNESS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KRISTIE BELL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT BY
THE CHAIR ON THIS POLICY AND
WHAT IS GREAT IS REASONABLE AND
GRANTING PROTECTIONS THAT
APPROPRIATE DISCLOSURES THAT'LL
ALLOW CALPERS TO ENSURE THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM COMPATIBLE
DATA QUICKLY COMPLETE COMPETE
SORRY. FOR SOUND INVESTMENT IN
THE PRIVATE MARKET WE THINK THE
BILL IS SUPPOSED TO BE AMENDED
STRIKES A DELICATE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE RIGHT OF THE PUBLIC
TO BE INFORMED ABOUT THE
PENSION SYSTEM BUSINESS. AND
THE RIGHT OF THE PENSION
SYSTEM'S EXERCISE THEIR
FIDUCIARY DUTIES AND MANAGING
THE ASSETS OF THE SYSTEM. THE
FUND THE RETIREMENT. OF OUR
MEMBERS. SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
HARD WORK AND RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
THREE EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY WE WILL MOVE TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE EIGHTY SIX.
YES E. V. MEASUREMENTS ZERO
COMMENTS AT THE LIMITED OF
COURSE TO. THE FORUM MEMBERS
JERRY BROWN ABOUT HALF OF THIS
YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN
NEUTRAL TO THIS POINT BUT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS- WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU- MARCHI FOR
US IN THE CALPERS STAFF FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER IS VERY
COMPLICATED. PRECIADO IT BUT-
WE CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIX SEEN ON
WILL CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM-
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY
WILL GO THE MODERATOR.
MODERATOR OF PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS ON AB
THREE EIGHTY SIX AND AGAIN
WOULD APPRECIATE KNOWING THE
NUMBER WITNESSES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ONE PARTY IN
THE QUEUE NINE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BILL
GIVEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PARTIES IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR HOMES
WE WILL. AND THEN TO- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION INTO WE DO HAVE
BOTH DAVID SOARES AND JANET
**** LISTED AS OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- MISTER SORES ARE YOU
BILL WILL TESTIFY. I DON'T
THINK YOU CHAIRMAN. ARE YOU MAY
PROCEEDS. IN AFTERNOON I'M
DAVID SORENSEN FIVE WITHIN
SANTA CRUZ FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS
AND I'M A CALPERS BENEFICIARY
RETIRED AFTER SERVING FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
PROSECUTOR IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. CONSECUTIVE TERMS
REPRESENTING BOTH THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND THE PROSECUTORS
IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THE RETIREE FULLY
SUPPORT CALPERS MAKING EFFORTS
TO KEEP A LID ON CURRENT
CONTRIBUTION RATES BUT WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS THE PUBLIC
TRUST FUNDS NOT BE PLACED INTO
THE SORT OF NON TRANSPARENT
INVESTMENT THAN IN THE RECENT
PAST SAID THE FORMER CALPERS
CEO TO FEDERAL PRISON. BILL
PURPORTS TO ENABLE DIRECT
LENDING OF TRUST FUNDS TO
PRIVATE BORROWERS BUT GOES TOO
FAR BY EXEMPTING THE
CONSTITUENT OWNERS OF THE BAR
OR THE LOAN TERMS AND THE
COLLATERAL OF PLEDGED FROM THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. CALPERS
ALREADY INVEST FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ONE POINT 4% OF THE
TRUST FUND AND PRIVATE DEBT
THROUGH ALTERNATIVE INVESTMENT
PARTNERSHIPS. WHICH THEY LACK
THE EXPERTISE TO MAKE
INTERNALLY. THE FEES THEY PAY
TO INVEST IN PRIVATE THAT MAKE
UP A SMALL PART OF THE EXTERNAL
MANAGEMENT FEES FROM
ALTERNATIVES AND REAL ESTATE
WHICH THEMSELVES MAKE UP A MERE
17% OF THE TOTAL ASSETS THE
CALPERS HAS UNDER MANAGEMENT.
LOOKING AT CALPERS PROJECT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET THESE EXTERNAL
MANAGEMENT FEES AS ADJUSTED TO
REFLECT PROFIT SHARING IS
REPORTED IN THE LATEST CAPPER.
WILL EXCEED ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS AN INCREASE OF
THIRTY PERCENT. THIS IS ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS ABOVE
ALL OTHER OPERATING EXPENSES
INCLUDING SALARIES AND BENEFITS
INVESTMENT IN TECHNOLOGY
CONSULTANTS AND FACILITIES. PUT
YOUR MAKE UP JUST SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND ONLY
INCREASED BY 3% THIS APPARENT
MANIA FOR HANGING EXTERNAL
TEAMS MIGHT NOT SUGGEST THE
CALPERS LEADERSHIP ARE BEING
SERIOUS ABOUT REDUCING CAN BE
OF THIS DIRECT LENDING PROGRAM.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY POINTED OUT
BUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE SUDDEN
RESIGNATION OF THE CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER LAST YEAR
WHEN IT WAS REVEALED IN THE
MEDIA THAT HE HAD SERIOUS
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST WITH SOME
OF THE SAME HEIGHT THE EXTERNAL
MANAGERS. ALL ONE WITH THE
RESIGNATION OF THE CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER WAS THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER CALPERS
AND THE CALPERS BOARD
PRESIDENT. ADMITTED TO
BLOOMBERG NEWS THAT THEY HAD
CHOSEN TO COVER UP G. I. O.'S
CONFLICTS THE MAJORITY OF THE
BOARD OF ADMINISTRATION FROM
THE F. DTC AND FROM THE PUBLIC.
WHEN STATE CONTROLLER BETTY YEE
DEMANDED AN INVESTIGATION THE
BOARD PRESIDENT TOOK THE MATTER
INTO CLOSED SESSION LAST AUGUST
AND NEVER REPORTED OUT. NOW
CALPERS WANTS TO EXEMPT
IMPORTANT INFORMATION THAT
COULD REVEAL SIMILAR INSIDER
DEALINGS FROM THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. WELL WE COULD
FULLY SUPPORT EXEMPTING PRIVATE
BUSINESS INFORMATION DISCLOSED
DURING THE UNDERWRITING
PROCESS. THIS CAVALIER ATTITUDE
BY THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE AND THE
BOARD PRESIDENT FORD SERIOUS
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. POSES IN
A COMPELLING WAY THAT WE CANNOT
TRUST CALPERS TO JUMP. THE
CONSTITUENT OWNERSHIP OF A
PRIVATE BORROWER THE LOAN TERMS
AND THE COLLATERAL PLEDGED FROM
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX GOES TOO FAR
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND SHOULD
NOT MOVE FORWARD IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. BUT ALSO LIKE IN CLOSING
TO NOTE THAT THERE WAS A VERY
STRONGLY WORDED LETTER SENT
FRIDAY BY DOCTOR. THICK TO
RECORD ALL THE CITY OF PASADENA
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. PREDICAMENTS SOARS
JANET **** AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY.
YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES AND YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY
THE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT EIGHT.
THREE EIGHTY SIX I'M JANET ****
I'M A LEGISLATION DIRECTOR
COUNTRY FIFTY TELECOM VALLEY
AND A GRATEFUL RECIPIENT OF A
CALPERS PENSION. MAKING TODAY
FOR THREE THIRTY SO OFTEN
VALLEY PROBLEM THREE CALIFORNIA
AND THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION. ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
WATCHING CALPERS FOR A LONG
TIME. WE DO NOT SEE ANY CRIED
USURY JUSTIFICATION FOR MORE
SECRECY ABOUT CALPERS PRIVATE
EQUITY OR DEBT HOLDINGS SH
CALPERS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT PRIVATE EQUITY IS BASED
ON SB FOUR THIRTY NINE
INTRODUCED BY JOE TOO MEDIUM
AND KATHLEEN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
BED BILL WHAT THE RESPONSE TO A
PARTICULAR SITUATION INVOLVING
VENTURE CAPITAL IN SILICON
VALLEY DURING THE TECH BUBBLE.
SHOULD CALPERS SECRETIVE
PRIVATE EQUITY POLICY HAS BEEN
A HIGHLY CONTENTIOUS TOPIC OR
BOARD STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS SH
YEAH AB THREE EIGHTY SIX F. THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW THE FUNDED
TO KEEP SECRET IF PRIVATE DEBT
INVESTMENTS WHICH ARE SOME OF
THE FUNDS MOST RISKY HOLDINGS.
AT THE PRESENT TIME AS WE'RE
ALL AWARE CALPERS HAS BECOME A
MAGNET FOR CONTROVERSY WHICH
HAS ONLY FUELED GENERAL
OPPOSITION TO DEFINED BENEFIT%
PUBLIC PENSION PLANS WHICH WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. TO FIND
CURRENTLY LACKS A PERMANENT
CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER AT THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTER NOTED. AND
IS OVERALL REPUTATION IS
CONTINUALLY IN QUESTION EACH
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THE
BENEFIT TO THE FUND TO ITS
MEMBERS AND BENEFICIARIES OR TO
THE BOARD FRAZIER A DUTY THAT
PASSAGE OF AB THREE EIGHTY SIX.
WE BELIEVE CALPERS NEEDS MORE
OVERSIGHT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
NOT LAST WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU MS ****
WOULD COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM- IS ARE THERE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH STEP%
TOWARD SPEAK. SEE NONE- IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES SO WISHING TO SPEAK
AT SEVEN IT WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR AND ASK FOR THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO TO THIS
BILL. AB. THREE EIGHTY SIX AND
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER AND PLAYED AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
EIGHTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE IN THE
QUEUE. THAT NUMBER IS GROWING.
FIND ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
LOOKED OVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE RETIREES IN
OPPOSITION. NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
A LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARE ROCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION FOR THE-
NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. S. C. T.
WHATEVER- REPRESENTING-
CALIFORNIA. PALANCE RETIRED
AMERICANS WHICH REPRESENTS A
MILLION- MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
EITHER ORGANIZATIONS- THE IN
OPPOSE DANA A. B. THREE EIGHT
SIX I'M ALSO REPRESENTING.
CENTRICA PARTY OF CALIFORNIA
THE LETTER ON FILE IN
OPPOSITION- UNFORTUNATELY
DIDN'T GET FORWARDED AND SO WE
GOT A FREE POSTAGE TO LATER
COMMENTS- BUT ISN'T IN THE-
STATE PORTAL THANK YOU TO BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS WITH OPPOSITION.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JJ TWO ONE SIX I'M A
BENEFICIARY CALPERS I BELIEVE
IN OPEN GOVERNMENT AND
THEREFORE OPPOSE THREE EIGHTY
SIX I HAVE A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION ON FILE BUT I HOPE
YOU ALL HAD A CHANCE TO SEE.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN
ROSENBAUM ON RESIDENT OF PALO
ALTO CAN UCR'S RETIREE AND MY
WIFE IS EUNICE TRS RETIREE. AND
I WOULD LIKE TRANSPARENCY. AND
I OPPOSE. IT ET A TWO THIRDS OF.
BY ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WORKERS
IN CALPERS DESERVE TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS MADE ON
THEIR BEHALF MY NAME IS ROSE
VAN WITH WITH THE GRASSROOTS
KANETO CLIMATE COALITION IN
THOUSAND OAKS AND I'M CALLING
TO OPPOSE AB THREE EIGHTY SIX.
THANK. NINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CHANDY
TRICK WITH THREE FIFTY VENTURA
COUNTY CRIME LAB WHOSE NUMBERS
LOT DETAILS ON THEIR
INVESTMENTS ESPECIALLY. IN BOB
HOPE YOUR- OPPOSE THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO MORE COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR AMONG THE COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND- IF I CAN
THE- TEST- MAKE MY COMMENTS FOR
SAY A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE A
SUMMER COOPER YOU'RE A
WILLINGNESS TO- AGREED TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT BEEN
NEGOTIATED- JUST RECENTLY-
BETWEEN ARCED COMMITTEE STUFF
AND- IN YOURSELF YOUR OFFICE.
IN IN- IN TERMS OF LEAD US
SUPPORT THE RESEARCH ALSO
REFERENCE TO PLEASE-
AMENDMENTS- BECAUSE THEY'RE
RELATIVELY LATE COMEDIAN I JUST
WANTED TO PUT ON THE RECORD MY
UNDERSTANDING AND ASSUMING
THAT. YOUR UNDERSTANDING IS THE
SAME I THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT
FOR US TO. RIGHT THE TO GET
THAT OUT HERE ON THE RECORD- IN
A IN A DO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE ON THE
DAIS HAVE RECEIVED. A MOCK UP
OF THE AMENDMENTS- HAS
UNDERSTOOD AND- AS NEGOTIATED
THEM WITH COMMITTEE STAFF- WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS DO. IS NARROW
THE BILL BY DELETING PROVISIONS
THAT EXEMPT FROM THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT MATERIALS OR
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
IDENTITY OF CONSTITUENT OWNERS.
AS WELL AS COLLATERAL SO THAT
THOSE CATEGORIES ARE STILL
SUBJECT TO P. R. A. DISCLOSURE-
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
IN SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
IN ACTUALITY BECAUSE OF THE
BILL'S DOUBLE REFERRAL IN THE
TIMING OF THAT I WAS JUST
REFERENCING. BUT I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR. THAT IS TO MY VOTE THESE
ARE- A CONDITION. AND I DO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO PULL BILL
BACK TO COMMITTEE AT A LATER
TIME SHOULD THE BILL BE AMENDED
A WAY THAT DOES NOT REFLECT OUR
AGREEMENT TODAY AGAIN ASSUMING
THAT WE HAVE AGREEMENT THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I'D I DO THINK
THAT. MUCH OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS. REAL AND
LEGITIMATE. IN PERHAPS DESERVES
SOME FURTHER ARTICULATION
CERTAINLY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND- I WOULD JUST ASK YOU AS
THE AUTHOR. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO THE OPPOSITION THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. UP TO
CONTINUE MOVING IN IN WHATEVER
DIRECTION. OF MIGHT LEAD TO
SOME MORE DETAIL IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE- WHAT ELSE MAY BE
SUBJECT TO. THE KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT I THINK
PEOPLE ARE ARE USED TO UP AT
OTHER LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AT
THIS POINT SO HI I WILL STOP
THEIR IN ASKING IF THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS- FIVE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE CENTER ALERT. ON
FIFTY S. I HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IN THE FIRST ONE
MIGHT BE TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT
JUST HAPPENED BECAUSE- I CAN
READ HE TEXT. AND I SORT OF
HEARD WHAT YOU SAID. BUT HOW
SPECIFICALLY TO THE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSED THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION I MEAN HOW DO THEY
MOVE TOWARD IT. WHAT IS HIS
BEST SEVERAL TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND- IT CERTAINLY OF
THE AUTHOR WISHES TO HELP
ANSWER THAT QUESTION- THAT'S
FINE. BUT IT'S HIS PREROGATIVE
BUT- I WOULD SEE. ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IT IS BEAST. THIS IS
THE ART TO OF WOOD I WOULD
ENUMERATORS ABOUT SIX.
SUBSTANTIVE CONCERNS ENUMERATED
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP BY THE OPPOSITION BUT THE
ARTS ARE TWO THAT HAVE BEEN
FULLY RESPONDED TO IN TERMS OF-
THEIR DESIRE FOR TRANSPARENCY
SO THIS LITERALLY TAKES. A TO
PERHAPS PERHAPS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT A MATTER OF OPINION
BUT TWO OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT. REQUEST THEY HAVE
MADE- AND AN AMENDED THEM SIR
WHICH I WOULD THINK WOULD BE TO
THEIR SATISFACTION CERTAINLY TO
MY SATISFACTION NOW- WHAT ELSE.
COULD BE DONE I THINK IS A
SECOND QUESTION THAT I WOULD
DEFINITELY HAVE TO REFER TO THE
AUTHOR. AND WHEN WE HEARD FROM
THE OPPOSITION NONE OF THE
OPPOSITION AND- THE AMENDMENTS
YET SAID CORRECT. HI THERE
THERE WAS LITTLE TIME. THE IS
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS-
GIVEN THE DAY OF THE WEEK IN-
WHERE WE ARE ON THE TIMELINE-
TO SPEAK TO EVERYONE- ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE- BUT THERE ARE
SOME MEMBERS OF OUR P. E. A.
WHO WERE AWARE. AND I BELIEVE
WE'RE GRATEFUL OF THE MOVEMENT-
THAT WAS MADE AT THIS POINT TO.
YOU KNOW AFTER. I THINK THE
MANY WEEKSOF WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE AND- AND
ALSO OUR COMMITTEE MORE
RECENTLY. THANK YOU ARE NOT AT
AND SOME OF US ARE SMILING
UNDER MASS AT THE FACT THAT THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE COULD DO
FOR THE WORKERS WERE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SO WE- SEE THIS
CONTINUING TO COME OUR WAY- I
WAS GONNA ASK A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WASN'T CLEAR FROM
READING THIS. IS AWARE WITHIN
THE PER SYSTEM INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE SO- THERE ARE TWO
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF THE PERS.
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OR A PERSON
VESTMENT COMMITTEE. ARE SUB
COMMITTEE OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS DO THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS INFORMATION. SO THAT
THERE'S SOME ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE SYSTEM I MEAN PEOPLE ARE
LIKE THEM. FOR TO SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY. UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD THERE BE ACCESS TO
PURCHASE MORE MEMBERS OF THIS
INFORMATION SENATOR ON THAT
MISTER BROWN IT'S THAT. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR
LAYERED- YES THAT THAT THE
QUICK ANSWER IS YES THE PERS
BOARD MEMBERS WOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO ANY INFORMATION THAT-
INVESTMENT STAFF HAS IN THEIR
POSSESSION AND OUR INVESTMENT
COMMITTEE IS A COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE. SO BASICALLY THERE WOULD
BE A MEASURE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
IF UNDER THIS BILL IT IS NOT
MADE PUBLIC IT IS MADE KNOWN TO
THE INDIVIDUAL ELECTED MEMBERS
OF THE PURSE BORDER ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE MEMBERS TEN IS THAT
CORRECT. WELL THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING CORRECT IT WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THEM IF THEY
REQUESTED TO VIEW IT. YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT AUTOMATICALLY
DISTRIBUTED TO EACH BOARD
MEMBER BUT THE BOARD MEMBERS
COULD REQUEST TO BE COME INTO
COME INTO THE BUILDING AND LOOK
AT IT WHILE. MMHM THIS HEARING
TO PUBLIC RECORD PEOPLE COME
BACK AND READ WHAT JUST GOT
SAID HOW OFTEN DOES THAT HAPPEN
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY NOT NEVER
HAPPENS AND IF SOMETHING WERE
TO GO SIDE WAYS AND INVESTMENT
AND NOBODY EVER KNEW TO THE
REQUESTED THAT THAT'S NOT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- I DON'T. HAVE ASSIST YOU
KNOW. I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION WROTE THAT I KNOW THAT
I'VE TAUGHT MY HEAD I HAVE MICE
CO IT HERE I HATE TO BRING HER
UP BUT SHE MAY HAVE MORE NO
LET'S DO THIS- IT'S COMING TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BY THE
TIME OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. IT WOULD BE NICE IF
YOU GET THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION SO THAT WERE REALLY
CLEAR BECAUSE I THINK THAT. HE
IS THE OPPOSITION. COMMENTS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND IF
ACCOUNTABILITY DOESN'T FACT
EXIST WHAT'S UNDERSTAND HOW IT
EXISTS AS IT COMES IN FROM. THE
AREA BECAUSE IF IT'S THAT.
THERE MIGHT BE. SOME CONCERN
ABOUT MALFEASANCE BUT PEOPLE
HAVE TO KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT WHERE
IT IS TO ASK WHERE IT IS THAT
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BE A GOOD
THING. BUT IF. THEY CAN DO A
RANDOM SELECTION OR
UNDERSTANDING OR SOMETHING THAT
THAT GUARANTEES THAT THERE WILL
BE ACCOUNTABILITY BACK WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT. SO ARE IF IT'S
OKAY WITH THE CHAIR I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT YOU. YOU
PROVIDE AN ANSWER TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBER SEN
PROBABLY COPY THOUGH LABOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BEFORE THE
JUDICIARY HEARING. KISS OF THE
WAR AWARE OF THAT. AND FRANKLY.
IF IT'S UP TO SAID ANYWAY IT
WILL BE PURSUED DURING THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HERE. OKAY
THANK YOU. IT IS AN EARLY
SENATE ROSA. YES- ALONG THE
LINES OF- WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
JUST LAID OUT AS FAR AS- THE
BOARD MEMBERS KNOWING NINE WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IS IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE YOU COULD DO IT NOW
OR YOU COULD DO IT LATER BEFORE
I JUDICIARY WE COULD SUMMARIZE
ALL THE WAYS IN WHICH YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S STILL GOING TO BE.
THE TRANSPARENCY THAT'S NEEDED
FOR US TO BE CONFIDENT THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST PUTTING INTO A
DARK HOLE AND SOMEBODY
SOMEWHERE SOMEHOW. OUR RETAINS
CONTROL AND MAKES DECISIONS
ABOUT THIS- THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
HAPPENS. A LOT OUT THERE IN THE
WORLD ESPECIALLY. YOU KNOW IN
ON WALL STREET- AND WE WANT OUR
FUNDS TO BE- HM PROTECTED
ENOUGH- I TAKE ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT. I HAVE ENORMOUS
CREDIBILITY WITH ME I KNOW
THEY'RE WATCHING OUT AND
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR OUT FOR.
THE WELL BEING OF THE FUNDS AND
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GONNA
DEPEND ON THOSE FUNDS FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT- SO THAT MEANS A LOT
TO ME- BUT I STILL THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO. HAVE THOSE
SORT OF STEP BY STEP HOW ARE WE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THERE IS-
ENOUGH OF AN ACCESS. THAT
THERE'S REAL- SUPERVISION OF
THESE FUNDS THANK YOU. DEGREE
LOOKING FOR RESPONSE AT THIS
TIME OR UPON THE CLOSE OF. THE
DEAL WILL ALLOW YOU TO RESPOND
TO THE EXTENT YOU WISH. AT THE
TIME YOUR CLOTHES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CENTER NEWMAN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SERVICE SO
I AM- NOTON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SO THIS WILL BE MY
LAST. BITE AT THIS APPLE. INTO
IF I MAY AND I THINK MANY WAS
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE WITH
THE OPPOSITION LAST WEEK- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT PRECEDED
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
ACCEPTED. WELL WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY. VENTURA IF MR SOURCES
STILL ON THE LINE IF I MIGHT
ASK HIM. TO RESPOND TO THE
PROPER AMENDMENTS SO FAR JUST
TO GET. A PLACE HOLDER FOR MY
VOTE BUT I TYSON FOR THE
LARGEST CHRISTIAN JUDICIARY
THAT WILL FOLLOW WHAT PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR QUESTION
THEN- HOPEFULLY. BY TIA OR
WHOEVER DOES THAT CAN GET HIM
ON A- BUDGET ELDERLY JUDGES
NEWMAN I HOPE I'M STILL ON THE
LINE NO WE CAN ONLY. AND CLEAR
SO WHAT CENTER NEWMAN POSES
QUESTION I DIED HOPEFULLY THAT
WAS CLEAR TO AYE IF YOU COULD
MAJORITY YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE CONVERSATION LAST WEEK- AND
IT PROVED THAT CONVERSATION
PROCEED THE AMENDMENTS. WERE
DISCUSSING TODAY SO IF WE CAN
GET YOUR REACTION- AT LEAST AT
THE CURRENT TIME. AS TO THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THOSE.
AMENDMENTS MEET YOUR CONCERNS
IF AT ALL. BOB WELL THERE IS
THERE'S MAKE PROGRESS- CENTER
NEWMAN THIRD THEY'RE BASICALLY
THERE ARE SIX EXEMPTIONS- TO
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT- IN THE
PROPOSED. BILL WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WE OF THOSE EXEMPTIONS TO
WERE ADDRESSED BY THESE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. THE ONES
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
MET BY THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
OR- THE IDENTITY OF ANY
CONSTITUENT OWNER OF THE BAR
WORK. AND THE- DEEP INSIDE I
WROTE IN MY- NEWSLETTER
ARTICLES OF EUROPEAN SUGGEST
AGAINST IN MY TESTIMONY IN THE
ASSEMBLY- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE'S A
COMPANY THAT'S OWNED BY
SOMEBODY- AND THIS WOULD JUST.
THE BILL AS AS WRITTEN WOULD
NOT ALLOW DISCLOSURE AND THE
OWNER AND I SUGGESTED THE
COMPANY WHAT IF IT WAS PUMP
JACK IN. NO ONE DISCLOSED THAT.
GAVIN NEWSOM BONES PUMP JACK
NOT THAT IT'S A BIT. THE
GOVERNOR WOULD AVAIL HIMSELF OF
THIS TYPE OF SITUATION. ON THE
OTHER IS- THE COLLATERAL
OFFERED FOR THE LOAN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT BECAUSE
THESE LOANS. WOULD BE FAIRLY
LONG TERM AND WOULD BECOME
ASSETS HELD. BY A PUBLIC TRUST
FUND IN OF COURSE WE WOULD WANT
TO KNOW ANYONE WOULD WANT TO
KNOW HOW THOSE. LOANS WOULD
WERE SECURED- BECAUSE
COLLATERALS ALWAYS CONCERNED
ANY TIME- THAT THERE'S LANDING-
ISSUE THAT IS NOT A- THE THAT
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT
THE TRONG. OF LONG I'M NOT
REALLY IS A VERY BASIC IT'S TO
YOU KNOW HOW HOW IS THIS AMONG
LAST FOR WHAT'S THE REPAYMENT
SCHEDULE- WHAT'S THE INTEREST
RATE. AND WE REALLY WE DON'T
SEE WHY THAT HAS TO BE THE
EXAM. WHAT WE DO AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT IS IT IT'S GOING
TO BE VERY HARD TO GET ANYONE.
TO TRIED TO BORROW FROM CALPERS
ASSUMING THAT CALPERS COULD
EVEN GET COMPETENT STAFF TO DO
UNDERWRITING- IF THEY HAD TO
DISCLOSE- AN OPEN THEIR BOOKS-
AN OPEN THERE INVESTMENT
COMMITTEE MEETINGS THAT OF THE
COMPANY NOT NOT CALPERS- TO
PUBLIC SCRUTINY UNDER THE T. R.
A. M. AND WE CERTAINLY. CAN
SUPPORT THOSE OTHER THREE
EXEMPTIONS AND YOU KNOW WOULD
BE HAPPY WITH YOUR OPPOSITION
IF THAT'S WHAT WAS ALL ALL THAT
WAS IN THE BILL. BUT OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IF WE- IF THIS
BECOMES AN ASSET HELD BY A
PUBLIC TRUST FUND. AND IT'S
OUTSIDE OF THE G. P. R. A. WHAT
THE TERMS ARE HOW THIS IS GOING
TO GET REPAID- WITH THE
INTEREST RATE IS THAT CETERA-
IT'S REALLY STILL KIND OF.
HOLLOW BUT I I'M REALLY GLAD TO
HEAR THAT SOME POLITICIANS
BEING MADE BECAUSE WE OFFERED-
IN AMENDMENT- SOME TIME AGO-
THROUGH THROUGH- DANNY BROWN
WHO WAS GREAT- IN- TALKING WITH
US BUT- COULDN'T BRING HIS BACK
A GOOD ANSWER- JUST SUGGESTING
THAT THESE THREE AREAS OF
CONCERN BE REMOVED. BUT
ALLOWING PRIVACY OF THE
UNDERWRITING PROCESS BECAUSE-
WE GET WHY BORROWERS- WOULDN'T
WANT TO JUST OPEN YOUR BOOKS
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT GET THE
LOAN AND THEN THERE ARE STILL-
SUBJECT TO SHOOT YOUR AGE SO- I
THINK THAT WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS BUT I THINK WE'RE
STILL VERY VERY CONCERNED- THAT
THE TERMS. I'M. NOT BE
EXEMPTION P. R. A. I. THE
APPRECIATE THAT SIR JOHN PLAY
TO HEAR THE WE ARE MAKING. AND
HOPEFUL THAT WE CONTINUE. THIS
CONGRESS AND MAKE IT PROGRESS
IT MOVED SO THANK YOU MISS. THE
CONSIDERED CENTER ALERT. SORRY
I'M JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
LONG BY PLAYED MAYBE ASK THE
AUTHOR. BECAUSE IT WAS
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE WERE
THREE MAJOR ISSUES AND TO
ADDRESS BY AMENDMENTS AND THEN
THERE'S ONE MORE IN THE LONG
TERM SO HOWEVER IT WAS
DESCRIBED. IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU'RE STILL WORKING ON WITH
THE OPPONENTS IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU MIGHT CONSIDER THAT THERE'S
A PLACE TO GO IS THIS MOVES TO
JUDICIARY CHIPSET I THINK
PIECES IN THERE I'M HAVE MISTER
BROWN ANSWER THAT. HI I CENTS
CONVERSATION WITH THEM- I THINK
YOU DAILY RUN TO GIVE CALPERS
AYE AYE WHAT I WOULD POINT OUT
AS WE DID HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS I THINK. IN IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR US TO EXEMPT THE
ENTIRE LOAN AGREEMENT WHICH I
THINK WE- YOU KNOW COULDN'T.
COME TO THAT AGREEMENT- BUT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW WE ARE
DISCLOSING A NUMBER OF THE
TERMS OF THE LOAN THERE IN
THERE THE AMOUNT OF THE LOAN.
THE INTEREST RATE THAT WE'RE
RECEIVING YOU KNOW THE
ANNUALIZED RETURNS SO THERE'S
INFORMATION IN THERE I THINK
THE ONE PIECE THAT'S PROBABLY
MISSING IS THE DURATION OF THE
LOAN BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING. WE COULD PROBABLY
WORK ON A AND- AND DISCLOSE BUT
I THINK IT'S THE ENTIRE LOAN
AGREEMENT BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME COVENANTS AND THINGS IN
THERE THAT THE POWER WAS NOT
GOING TO WANT. OUT THERE FOR
COMPETITIVE REASONS. FOUR WELL
I WOULD JUST SUGGEST WITH THE
ONE THING YOU SAID STILL MIGHT
BE ABLE TO BE THERE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT AND SEE IF. BY
THE TIME YOU GET TO JUDICIARY
THERE'S AN AMENDMENT THAT THAT
ALLOWS FOR THAT THERE BUT- THAT
WOULD ADDRESS IN SOME MANNER
THE THREE MAJOR POINTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED. THE N.
ANYWAY THANK YOU IT AND I WOULD
JUST MAKE AS A COMMENT. THE ED.
I READ ALL THIS I HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING AT BEST I CAN AND IN
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE
SIDE BARS THAT HAD IN RELATION
TO THESE AMENDMENTS THERE WAS
THE DISCUSSION THAT THIS IS
STILL COMING TO JUDICIARY AND
SO I THINK THAT THERE STILL CAN
BE SOME OF THESE THINGS BUT
ADDRESS DID NOT COMMITTEE BUT
THIS IS PROGRESS OF THE
AMENDMENTS AT THE COMMITTEE HAS
HAS WORKED ON HERE SO. I AM
WILLING TO VOTE TO MOVE ALONG
IN AND JUST TAKE AT FAITH THE
STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. ON THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
THANK YOU SENATOR WORD AND- AND
I THINK THOSE LAST- QUESTIONS
OR- SORT OF SORT OF GOOD
EXAMPLES IT'S NOT TYPICAL OF
THE WHAT I'M CALLING
ARTICULATION OR DETAIL IS SAID
THE BILL DIDN'T REALLY COME
INTO OUR COMMITTEE ORIGINALLY
WITH THAT KIND OF DETAIL BUT
THE KIND OF DETAIL THERE'S
THEIR WAYS TO DO IT WITHOUT-
WITHOUT HIM IN SOMETIMES IN
TERMS OF WE'LL UNDERSTAND
WITHOUT EVEN CROSSED HAVING THE
INFORMATION YOU KNOW TO KNOW
HOW MANY LOANS. ARE OUT THERE
WHAT TERM SUPPORT DURATION AND
HAVE A SEPARATE LIST OF WHO THE
CONSTITUENT OWNERS ARE WITHOUT
COSTA DILUTION DOESN'T OUT
ANYBODY ABOUT ANYTHING REALLY
HAD TO SHOWS- THE REAL
INVESTORS- WHICH ARE- HE KNOWS
BOTH THE CALPERS RETIREES
SICKENING IN THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING- WHAT'S
GOING ON OUT THERE YOU KNOW IN
IN SEPARATE COLUMNS IN A
SPREADSHEET FASHION SO THOSE
ARE KIND OF THINGS- I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE- I KNOW THE AUTHORS
BUT- TAKING ON A BIG. THE
LEADERSHIP ROLE TO TRY TO GET
THIS WORKED OUT WE APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH AND CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE- IN RECENT TIMES IN A
WEEK YOU PROBABLY WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE AND GET OUT YOUR OTHER
BILLS SO WE'RE GONNA ALLOW YOU
TO DO THAT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU IN IN YOUR STAFF
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
HELP AND ALL THE COMES FROM THE
CENTERS. YOU RECOGNIZE THE BIG
ISSUES WITH THE- THE RETIREES
YOU KNOW WHAT I DID GET THAT-
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
PENSIONS OR HOLD SECURE THE
AVERAGE PENSION FOR A CALPERS
RETIREES ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH BEFORE
RETIREMENT IT'S NOT A LOT OF
MONEY WE THE COULD BE PAYING
RENT OR MORTGAGE UTILITIES PUT
FROM YOUR TABLE SO WE WANT TO
MAKESURE THAT- WE DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEM- CALPERS SPENT
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
EVERY BILLION DOLLARS INVESTED
IN PRIVATE INVESTMENTS THIS IS
MEMBERS MONEY WHICH CANNOT BE
USED TO STRENGTHEN THE
RETIREMENT HEALTH THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE MONEY TO BE
INVESTED AS THE PAYING AN
OUTSIDE FIRM THE BILL ACTUALLY
HAS A HIGHER TRANSPARENCY
THRESHOLD THEY CURRENTLY EXIST.
THE HIGHER FINANCIAL MANAGERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THIS. THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE
FOR. BUT A MOTION. THIS SO
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW SO WE'LL
COME BACK WITH THE CONSULTANT
FOR THE ROLL CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. COURTESY HI BUT AS
THE I OR TROUBLED. WRESTLE
RUSSELL I LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN NEWMAN I. ALL RIGHTY
THEN THOSE UNDERSTAND THEN THE
VOTERS FOR- WITH ONE NON
PROTEIN AND SO THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THE-
WHO MOVE RIGHT ALONG TO THE
NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA WHICH
IS YOUR BILL SO MEMORY BE SIX
FIFTY SEVEN. AND THE TO READY
TO PRESENT THAT ONCE RADIALIS
INFRASTRUCTURE COLLEAGUES THE
STATE CIVIL SERVICE TAX
ESTABLISHES STANDARDS FOR THE
USE OF PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS WEST AGENCIES WILL
PRESCRIBE CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THESE THE PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS SHOULD BE USED
SPARINGLY WHEN THEY'RE FUNDED
FULL TIME POSITIONS NOT BEING
FILLED. THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
LEASE VACANCIES ARE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS SUCH AS PHYSICIANS
SURGEONS PSYCHOLOGIST AND
DENTIST. PLEASE PROFESSIONALS
ARE CONTRACTED CONSISTENTLY
SOMETIMES WITHOUT DO BECAUSE-
WE'RE IMPACTING THE QUALITY
CARE. TO PATIENTS SB SIX FIVE
SEVEN PROVIDE PROTECTIONS AND
TRANSPARENCY TO THE STATE'S
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
PROFESSIONALS BY PROHIBITING A
STATE AGENCY FROM ENTERING INTO
A CONTRACT. PROFESSIONAL FOR
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE CONSECUTIVE DAYS. OF THREE
AND SIXTY FIVE. NONCONSECUTIVE
DAYS A TWENTY FOUR MONTH
PERIOD. DEFINING PROFESSIONAL
TO INCLUDE AMONG OTHERS A
PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON DENTIST A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST. EMPLOYER
TO EMPLOYEE UNION THE CERTAIN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITH ME
TODAY IS WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT
FOR DOCTORS TOUR BUS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. SB LOCAL TWO ZERO
SIX. THANK YOU ROOM DR STUART
BUSSY IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YOU
MAY PROCEED. DOCTORS DURABLE CO
WITH US IN- ONE MAKE SURE
YOU'RE NOT MUTED BECAUSE WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU YET. MAYBE WE
SHOULD MOVE ON TO RYAN CAMAS
RANKIN ALSO. WITH SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL SO RYAN YOU MAY
PROCEED AND THEN WE COME BACK.
TO DOCTORS TO A POLICY. YES
THANK YOU TEACHER AND- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NEW
DOCTOR RYAN JAM- THE UNIVERSITY
BOARD MEMBER AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I SUPPORT THE THAT STATE
DID SHOULD BE LESS CONTRACTORS
A CITY YOU USING. MILLIONS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WASTING
MONEY BOB FOR YEARS GOING ON
FOR YEARS AND IT IS THOUGHT TO
HAVE PROTECTED THEM THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS
BASED. FOR THE CONTRACT TO
DECIDE TO BECOME STATE
EMPLOYEES IS MORE THAN ENOUGH
TIME. TO MAKE THAT DECISION AND
HAVING STATE EMPLOYEES- WE WILL
GET BETTER QUALITY OF CARE
BETTER WORK. I EXPECT THE
SAUDIS AND HAVING EMPLOYEES
THERE ARE VESTED IN THE STATE
SYSTEM IS BETTER THAN HAVING
CONTRACTORS WHO HAVE NO
INTEREST IN OUR GOVERNMENT AND
OUR SYSTEM- SO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BILL. I SUPPORT THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE MORE STATE
EMPLOYEES AND I SUPPORT THAT-
WE STOP WASTING MONEY
CALIFORNIA TAX DOLLARS. ON
CONTRACTORS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU YOUR TEST- LET ME GO
AND ASK IF TALK TUBA. OF IF SO
YOU MAY PROCEED. NOT HEARING
DOCTORS TOUR BUS SEAT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND- MOVE ON
WITH SUPPORT TESTIMONY AND OF-
STAFF CAN LET ME KNOW IF
DOCTORS TUBA CM BRIBES DURING
THE PROCESS HERE IF NOT WE'LL
JUST CONTINUE TO PROCEED AS WE
USUALLY DO- IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS OR ANYONE WHO IS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN. A SCENE KNOWN COME
FORWARD WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW
ROOM AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
THERE TO TESTIFY LOCAL THE
MODERATOR. MODERATOR PLEASE-
QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT TESTIMONY
FREE B. SIX FIFTY SEVEN AND WE
APPRECIATE KNOWING THE NUMBER
OF SPEAKERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE- FOR
PARTIES AND THAT NUMBER IS
GROWING. ONE ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HERE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES OKAY THIS IS DOCTOR STUART
BURKE CHAU GOT BACK IN THE
QUEUE- AND I WISH TO TESTIFY
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CORTES
HE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF DR
STUART BUT YOU PRESIDENT OF THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
GENETIC ASKED ME TO OUR
DISTRICTS AND THE STRONG
SUPPORT. SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN.
ONCE SIGNED INTO LAW WILL
IMPROVE THE HIRING PROSPECTS OF
STATE DOCTORS AND DENTISTS DR
JIM SUGGESTED MINIMAL HELP
REDUCE. THE CIVIL SERVICE
MAKING TEARING TAKE MILLIONS OF
THE TAXPAYERS. PER DECADE TO
THE STATE IS CONTRACTED OUT
PARKING UNITS SIXTEEN
VACANCIES. AND BARGAINING UNIT
NINETEEN VACANCIES TO EXPENSIVE
PRIVATE REGISTRIES. MEANWHILE
OUR CIVIL SERVICE WORKFORCE IS
DWINDLED BURGLARIZED THE
REASONS. RELATED TO THE
DIVERSION OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ALLOCATED. TO THE CIVIL
SERVICE POSITIONS ARE BEING
USED TO PAY CONTRACTORS. AND
THE RESULT HAS BEEN INADEQUATE
SALARY INCREASES ANY MAKE
RECRUITING EFFORTS AND
SIGNIFICANT SIGN UP BONUS SB
SIX FIFTY SEVEN IS A STEP TO
CORRECT THIS IMBALANCE.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE CLAIMS THAT
THEY PREFER CIVIL SERVICE OVER
CONTRACTORS. BEHAVIOR INDICATES
OTHERWISE WHETHER NEGOTIATING
OUR AMMO USER MEETING WITH YOU
áP AND ARE CONTRACTING OUT
COMMITTEES. ONLY LIP SERVICE.
HAS BEEN PAID TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS- THE GROUP
RETENTION BONUS INTO UP OVER
REJECT NO NO THAT A SHORT CYCLE
BACON RATE IS NEARLY 50% AT
SOME DSHS 80% SHE KALINJAR
LIBERALLY USES ITS EMERGENCY
POWERS UNDER GOVERNMENT CODE
ONE NINE ONE THREE SIX TO HIRE
PRIVATE REGISTRY PSYCHIATRIST
YOU TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
DOLLARS TWICE THE SALARY OF OUR
PSYCHIATRIST AND THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE SIXTY FIVE DOLLAR AN
HOUR MINISTRY TO TEACH. SOME OF
THESE CONTRACTORS HAVE MADE
SEVENTY THOUSAND A MONTH AND
ONE EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE MONTH. ACCORDING
TO THE DATA SUPPLIED BY THE
STATE. OUR HEALTH CONTRACT ARE
THE CARD ACROSS USED ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
BESIDES THIS MONETARY WASTE THE
INTERNMENT CONTRACTORS PROVIDE
LESS CONTINUITY CARE THE
CALIFORNIA GENERATION MENTALLY
ILL THIS IS IN CONFLICT WITH
THE EXPRESS GOAL TO THE PLOT
AND COLEMAN COURT ORDERS. ALSO
OUR CIVIL SERVICE MORALE
SUFFERS WHEN CONTRACTORS A
PRESENT FOR MANAGING WORKING
ALONGSIDE SOMEONE WHO MAKES
TWICE AS MUCH AS YOU DO. BUT
ENJOYS PREFERENTIAL WORK
SCHEDULES I KNOW MANDATORY ON
CALL. COMMANDER NO WONDER THAT
MANY OF OUR DOCTORS QUIT. THEIR
JOBS TO BECOME CONTRACTORS. SB
FORTY TWO TWO. OUR DOCTORS TO
STAY BY CREATING A STATE
REGISTRY WITH HIGHER PAY SB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN ACCESS TO
COMPLIMENTARY BOOK AND BILL. BY
RESTRICTING THE CONTRACTORS
TOTAL TIME TO THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS. STATE THERE
SHOULD. THAT AMOUNT OF TIME
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR A
DOCTOR TO DECIDE IF HE OR SHE
WANTS TO REMAIN WATCH TO BECOME
A STATE EMPLOYEE. IN ADDITION
IT'S BILL PROVIDES
CONFIDENTIALITY TRANSPARENCY
FLEXIBILITY TO RENEW THE
CONTRACTOR IF THE AGENCY AND
CHAU MISSISSIPPI I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SIX
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WERE TO GO BACK
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR IS A
LESS UNDERSTOOD IT UP THAT WAY
BY THE WAY FOR THOSE LISTENING
THAT WAS ACTUALLY. ONE OF THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES JUST
GETTING ON- OF THE A LITTLE BIT
LATE. BUT WE WANT TO GO TO
SUPPORT. WITNESSES SO ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THIS TESTIMONY
IS LIMITED TO NAME. AFFILIATION
IF ANY- AND- YOUR SUPPORT- JUST
THE WORDS OF. HIGH MINIMUM
MOVED OPPOSITE WITNESSES- IN
JUST A MOMENT WE'LL GO THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESS- I UNDERSTOOD
THERE WAS OF FOUR PLUS AT THE
TIME WITH US CHECK. A MODERATOR
IN THANK YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU AND WE DO HAVE FOUR PARTIES
IN THE COMMENT QUEUE LINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CARD
CHAIRMAN CORTESE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- DOUG CHIPATA ON BEHALF
OF THE UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS ACTUALLY LOCAL COOL
TRICKS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KOK WARY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING AS
CO SPONSORS SUPPORT THE BILL.
SIXTY SEVEN. NINE ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR GEORGE OSBORNE ATV IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS NATURE
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DID YOU EVER SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO FOR THE
LINES IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION UNDER CAESAR'S THERE
IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION. HER
TESTIMONY ON SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
WILL ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THE SCENE
NO ONE. STEP FORWARD- CHECK
OVER FOR ROOM AND THERE'S NO
WITH THIS IS THERE BACK TO YOU
MODERATOR- COULD YOU PLEASE Q.
OPENING OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ONLY BE. SIX FIFTY SEVEN AND
AGAIN OF WE APPRECIATE THE
NUMBER. THANK YOU MR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX
FIFTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU OF THAT BRINGS US BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMONER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'VE SEEN NONE I
WILL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
GIVEN OPTION TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MOTION ON THE B.
SIX TWO TWO SEVEN IS SO MOVED
BY SENDER TO RUSSELL WILL GO
THROUGH OUR CONSULTANT AND AS
FOR THE ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BILL BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. COURTESY HI. BUT
AS THE I OR TROUBLED. THE
TROUBLED NOW RESSA THE REST SO
I LAYERED HI THERE I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN AYE OKAY SO THE VOTE WAS
OF FOUR ON A ONE NO ON THE BILL
ITSELF. YOU CAN FOR BEING HERE.
COLONEL GO ON TO THE NEXT
SADDAM. ON OUR AGENDA. EXCUSE
ME OKAY THANKS TO THE
MERCHANDISE IS AB ONE TWENTY
THREE THIS IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. WELCOME HILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR EVENING
MAYBE AND MEMBERS WE HAVE YET
TO TACKLE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLES TO PREVENT WORKING
PARENTS AND CARE GIVERS FROM
USING PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND
THAT'S THE LACK OF INCOME
REPLACEMENT AB ONE TWO THREE
WILL ALLOW WORKERS USING THE
STATE'S PAID FAMILY PROGRAM TO
RECEIVE UP 290% OF THEIR INCOME
WHILE ON LEAVE THIS PROGRAM IS
ENTIRELY FUNDED BY WORKERS YET
THE BENEFITS AREN'T
REALISTICALLY ACCESSIBLE FOR
MANY LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES UNDER THE CURRENT
PROGRAM A WORKER ONLY RECEIVED
6270% OF THEIR INCOME WHILE ON
LEAVE. THE CURRENT STRUCTURE A
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER EARNING
FOURTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR WOULD
ONLY RECEIVE 60% OF THEIR WAGES
THE LOWEST WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE FOR ANY MINIMUM WAGE
WORKER IN THE COUNTRY. EVEN IF
THEY'RE WORKING FULL TIME THE
CURRENT RATE WOULD ONLY PROVIDE
THEM ABOUT ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR DOLLARS A
MONTH. BARELY COVERING THE
AVERAGE RENT FOR A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT. PARENTS ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE BILLS THE
PROGRAM DOESN'T PROVIDE
FAMILIES ENOUGH TO LIVE ON
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN A
FAMILIES ACTUALLY FACING
INCREASED EXPENSES FROM A
NEWBORN OR MEDICALLY FOR
SERIOUS ILLNESS. THIS HOMER
PROGRAM WAS CREATED TO AVOID
FORCING WORKERS TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN BEING PRESENT AT HOME
TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES IN
TIMES OF NEED. ARE WORKING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. AB ONE TWO
THREE WHAT INSURER PAID FAMILY
LEAVE IS A BENEFIT THAT ALL
WORKERS CAN ENJOY BY GUARANTEE
90% OF THE INCOME REPLACEMENT.
BECAUSE BELIEVE BENEFITS ARE
SUBJECT TO STATE INCOME TAXES
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW MOST LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME MIDDLE INCOME
WORKERS TO RECEIVE THEIR FULL
TAKE HOME PAY. I HAVE A WITNESS
ON THE PHONE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH- IN FACT IT AGAIN
AS A JURY CENTAVOS LEAD WITNESS.
WE WILL GO TO THE LEAD WITNESS-
IN AS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
TIME. YES THANK YOU- HOPE ALL
YOU CAN HEAR ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. MY NAME IS
JERRY SANDEL I LIVE IN SAN
DIEGO I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION. ENTER INVOICES WELL-
AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE TWO THREE. WHEN MY DAUGHTER
WAS BORN I DIDN'T KNOW I HAD
THE RIGHT TO TAKE LEAVE AND NOW
CURRENT INTO SOMEBODY INFORMED
ME OF THE RIGHT. IT MEANT THE
WORLD TO ME SPENDING OUT SOME
TIME WITH MY NEWBORN HAVING
THEIR FIRST ENCOUNTERS AND ALSO
HELPING AROUND THE HOUSE. I
REALLY I MY DAUGHTER CHANGE ON
LIFE FAR TOO OFTEN WEEKS WITH-
BUT WHEN I GOT MY FIRST
PAYCHECK FROM THE EDT I
REALIZED I COULDN'T AFFORD TO
STAY ON I'M TRYING TO LEAVE. I
KNOW I WASN'T NOT I WAS GOING
OR NOT GOING TO RECEIVE THE
FULL PAY. AND IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ME TO PAY MY BILLS SO I
MADE A DECISION TO GO BACK TO
WORK I ENDED UP WORKING TWO
JOBS TO SUPPORT MY FAMILY- I
WAS EXCITED TO GO HOME AND TELL
MY DAUGHTER LOVER- BEEN I
REALLY I BECAME AN ADVOCATE
BECAUSE I. USE IT FIVE I NEED
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN THE
FUTURE- I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. I AM
ALSO- ANOTHER KID BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT OTHER PARENTS TO GO
TO THE SAME THING I WENT
THROUGH. HI INCREASING THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT 290% WILL MEAN THAT
I AND OTHER PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE
TO TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE BUT
IF NO ACTION IS TAKEN THIS YEAR
THE WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE WILL.
ACTUALLY GO BACK DOWN 255%
WHICH IS UNACCEPTABLE ARE YOU
TO VOTE ON A. B. YES ON AB. ONE
TWO THREE TWO EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU SAN
VOLKER BACK WITH THE ROOMS ARE.
WHO TO SPEAK IN SOME. OF AB ONE
TWO THREE. SEEN OF WILL CHECK
YOUR FULL ROOM FOR WOMEN. I
THINK A SEE NO I DO SEE NINE-
THE MA NOW MODERATE TO QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT. ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWO THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND IT PRODUCT. ARTESIAN THE Q.
ONE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS
CHRIS THOUGHT IT OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MARGARITA SHE
ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
ON THE COURT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRST FIVE SO SHE
SHALL OF CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTOR
FOR. NINE ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN AND
GIRLFRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND A
GOOD EVENING AT TEN MEMBERS
THIS IS JESSICA STENDER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
INCOME SUPPORT. NINE ONE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS WILLIAM MUNSON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MY
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS KATIE
WATER WITH A CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO
TREE BECAUSE OUR CURRENT WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATES THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE MUST BE
INCREASED SO ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN USUALLY FIND A PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PICTURE GEN PARTS OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHOULD YOU EVER
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI A MIXTURE
MEMBERS COUNTY DOWN OFTEN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN COURT. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- THROUGH- IS NOT LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL ASK WHO'S ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE TO
TESTIFY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
HI THIS IS AB ONE TWO THREE
FOUR ONE TWENTY THREE. LOOK THE
OVERFLOW ROOM ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THERE TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION IT WILL COME BACK TO
YOU MODERATOR- IN THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR QUEUING UP.
WITNESSES WORKING PROPOSITION
WITNESSES TO AB ONE TWENTY
THREE AND PLEASE LET US KNOW
THE NUMBER. AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER THAN MY NUMBER. WE HAVE
ONE PARTY IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU. THAT PARTY DROPPED FROM
THE LINE WE HAVE NO PARTIES IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OR THEIR QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS-
AT ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT
TO SPEAK TO SENATOR ALSO YEAH.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
IS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING
FOR THE PROGRAM FOR THE WORKING
PEOPLE THEMSELVES AND THE ONES
WHO NEED IT THE MOST ARE THE
ONES WHO GETTING THAT LESS OR
AT LEAST- SO I'M REALLY GLAD
YOU WENT TO THE HEART OF THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE- EVERY PARENT
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT THE
ABILITY NOT JUST THE- RIGHT. IN
A WRITTEN ON A PIECE OF PAPER
AND PUT ON THE SHELF BUT THE
ACTUAL ABILITY TO TAKE THIS
LEAVE TO BE WITH THEIR- WITH
THEIR CHILDREN SO. I THESE
AGREE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE CENTER OF ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE DAIS WELCOME
BACK TO THE AUTHOR AND- I'M
SORRY CENTER NEWMAN YES PLEASE
JUST. JUST VERY QUICKLY I JUST
WANTED TO ECHO. THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE GARAGE OF.
MENU ASSEMBLY WILL BRING THIS
BILL- AND FOR LOOKING OUT FOR
WORKERS. YOU KNOW BOTH PARENTS.
WHO HAVE WHO HAVE EARNED THE
RIGHT TO SPEND TIME WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND ACTUALLY WHERE WE
BENEFIT- IN MANY WAYS FROM
GIVING THEM THE RIGHT SHOULD
THANK YOU BUT IT'S WORTH BUILT
IT- THANK YOU- AND NOT. AS A
RESTORING THE CITY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND POLITICOS YOU
MAY AT THIS TIME. M. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION ON EXPANDING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN A VARIETY
OF A AND PROTECTED FAMILY LEAVE
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS AND EARLY
ON- THE CONCERN OF OUR OFFICE
AND CONTINUES WE ARE CONCERNED.
IT IS YES YOU CAN EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF WEEKS AND THAT WORKS
FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR AN
EMPLOYER WHO SUBSIDIZES BAD. A
FAMILY LEAVE. THE PROBLEM
CONTINUES TO BE THAT WORKING
FOLKS. THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD THE
LEASE STILL PAY THE ONE POINT
2% OR WHAT TO ONE POINT 5%
OTHER PAY ROLL INTO A FUND THAT
THEY'LL NEVER BE ABLE TO
ACCESS. SO I ALTHOUGH I'M VERY
PROUD AND HAVE. JOINED OTHER
PINCIPLE AUTHORED AUTHORED.
BILLS TO HELP THIS
ADMINISTRATION EXPAND THE WAYS
THEY THOUGHT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TO BE EXPANDED. IT WOULD BE AN
INJUSTICE TO NOT CONTINUE THAT
THIS YEAR. THANKS TO OUR BUDGET
I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO
EXTENDED THE FIFTY FIVE. THE
SIXTY PERCENT. SIXTEEN SO
CALLED 70% FOR ANOTHER YEAR-
BECAUSE NOT WITH A SENSE ADDED
THIS YEAR 55% ARE BUDGET HAS
THAT LANGUAGE TO EXTEND IT.
HOWEVER THE REALITY IS BECAUSE
OUR MINIMUM WAGE WENT UP AT A
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER DOESN'T
EVEN QUALIFY FOR THE SEVENTY
PERCENT. SO EVEN A MINIMUM WAGE
WORKER IS ONLY GETTING 60% OF
THEIR ACTUAL INCOME. THERE IS
NO WAY I HAVE YET TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO BELIEVES. THAT HE
ESPECIALLY SINGLE MOTHER WHO
WHO IS BARELY MAKING ENDS WE
CAN ACTUALLY TAKE TIME OFF AT
60% OF THEIR INCOME. IF THEY'RE
WORKING ON A MINIMUM WAGE JOB
OR EVEN A LITTLE BIT MORE. SO I
THINK THIS IS IMPERATIVE AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. AND IN THE
FUTURE ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY
HAS THE RIGHT IT TO THIS
IMPORTANT BENEFIT THAT THEY'RE
ALL PAYING INTO IT. WHAT LAST
FOUR NINE THREE GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE DID WE HAVE A
MOTION ON. THE BILL SENATOR
ALSO MOVED IT- WILL MOVE TO A
ROLL CALL VOTE. THANK YOU TO
THE CONSULTANT. THE MOTION IS
TO. BUT FIRST R REFER TO THE
CAN ON APPROPRIATION. COURTESY
HI. BUT DOES THE I OR TROUBLED
BY. A TRAVEL GUIDE THE RUSSELL
I. WRESTLE I LAYERED HI. THERE
I NEWMAN HI. NEWMAN AYE THROUGH
THE BILLS OF THE UNANIMOUS VOTE
THANK YOU. NEXT ON OUR AGENDA
IS AB ONE OH FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN IN THE WELCOME TO
PRESENT AS SOON AS WE GET YOU
ALL SET UP IN SENATORS HERE.
WITH THE PODIUM SANITIZER
SHOULD. SPEAK MORE
APPROPRIATELY IDEAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS AFTERNOON DO YOU.
MEMBERS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON HI
FIRST LIKE TO STATE THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AND I
THANK THE CHAIR IN HIS
COMMITTEE STAFFER CONSULTING
HAS CONSULTING TEAM WORKING
WITH MY STAFF TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CHEERS CONCERNS ARE
KEEPING THE SPIRIT OF WHAT I'M
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH INTACT
WHICH IS TO SEE UPWARD MOBILITY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. MEMBERS
TODAY ARE PRESENTING AB ONE OH
FIVE A BILL THAT IDENTIFIES AND
REFORMS PROCESSES. THAT HINDER
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM. OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS THE SACRAMENTO BEE HAS
PUBLISHED A SERIES OF LETTERS
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN EMPLOYEES. WORKING
ORGANIZATIONS- SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
OUR CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM.
AND THE OFFICE OF STATE
PUBLISHING. ALL OF THESE
INSTANCES HAVE A COMMON
DENOMINATOR THERE ARE BARRIERS
TO UPWARD MOBILITY AND
INCLUSION. LAST YEAR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TOOK A BOLD STEP FORWARD
BY SIGNING MY BILL AB NINE
SEVENTY NINE WHICH REQUIRES
EACH PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATION
WHOSE PRINCIPAL EXECUTIVE
OFFICES ARE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF DIRECTORS FROM UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITY. ON ITS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THE GOAL
WAS PLAIN AND SIMPLE WE NEED TO
INCREASE UPWARD MOBILITY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THIS WAS A PRAISE WORTHY
STEP FOR EMPLOYEES IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. HOWEVER THERE
ARE PERPETUAL BARRIERS TO
UPWARD MOBILITY THAT EXIST IN
OUR PUBLIC SECTOR CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM. IT IS IN THIS SPIRIT
THAT I PUT FORWARD A NUMBER OF
CIVIL SERVICE REFORMS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN AB ONE OH FIVE.
DIVERSITY FOR STARTERS AB ONE
OH FIVE CALLS FOR DIVERSITY ON
ALL STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT HAVE
VOLUNTEERS AS YOU KNOW THE
CONSTITUTION DOES NOT ALLOW
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT BASED ON
RACE GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION IN THE OPERATION OF
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. EDUCATION
AND CONTRACTING. THEREFORE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD NOT REQUIRE
DIVERSITY REGARDING BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT SOLELY HAVE
STATE EMPLOYEES. HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE IS ALLOWED TO
REQUIRE DIVERSITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS WHERE THE BOARD
MEMBER OR COMMISSIONER IS A
VOLUNTEER. WITH THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE CHAIR OF ALL INTO YOUR
MEMBER OF COMMISSIONER OR
COMMISSIONER IS DEFINED AS
SOMEONE WHO IS SELECTED TO
SERVE ON A BOARD OR COMMISSION
WHO DOES NOT. WHO DOES NOT
RECEIVE ANY COMPENSATION OR
FINANCIAL GAIN FROM ANY STATE
AGENCY. A VOLUNTEER MAY RECEIVE
PER DIEM AND A VOLUNTEER SHOULD
NOT BE CONSIDERED TO BE AN
EMPLOYEE SOLELY ON THE BASIS OF
RECEIVING PER DIEM. AB ONE OH
FIVE SIX SIX TO DIVERSIFY THE
POSITIONS OF VOLUNTEER BOARD
MEMBERS AND COMMISSIONERS AS
VACANCIES BECOME. AVAILABLE
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
ESTABLISH A PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES DIVERSITY AND BEST
PRACTICES IN EACH ASPECT OF THE
DESIGN ANNOUNCEMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION OF EXAMINATIONS
FOR THIS TALISMAN OF EMPLOYMENT
LISTS. A DIVERSE PERSPECTIVE IN
ALL ASPECTS OF THE HIRING
PROCESS PROVIDES FOR MORE
DIVERSE WORKFORCE AND BETTER
OUTCOMES. AB ONE OH FIVE
PROVIDES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES. DEVELOP MODEL
UPWARD MOBILITY GOALS TO
INCLUDE RACE GENDER AND LGBTQ
AS FACTORS TO THE EXTENT
PERMISSIBLE UNDER STATE AND
FEDERAL EQUAL PROTECTION LAWS.
MEMBERS THE INCLUSION OF THESE
FACTORS ARE SIMPLY MEANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
DIVERSITY. I'M AWARE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF TWO OH NINE AND I
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT FALL VIOLATE. THE
CONSTITUTION. THIS BILL ALSO
GOES FURTHER TO INCLUDE. ISSUES
OF INCLUSION. ADVERSE AN
ADVERSE ACTIONS. MEMBERS OVER
THE PAST YEAR ISSUES OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION HAVE BEEN A TOP AREAS
OF CONCERN NATIONALLY AND HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
HAS BEEN NEARLY A YEAR SINCE
GOVERNOR BROWN'S REORGANIZATION
PLAN FOR CIVIL SERVICE. COLLEGE
ARE HAS PROVIDED US OVER SEVEN
YEARS OF DATA THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THAT THERE ARE PROCESSES IN
PLACE THAT HINDERED UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFINE TUNE OUR
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS A
MANUAL I'M A FOR CO FOUNDER
DIRECTOR ABOUT REACH COALITION
OF BLACK EMPLOYEES AND CHRIS
LOXTON. WITH THE COALITION FOR
JUST AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SUBMIT A BROOM WHO MOVED TO
READ SUPPORT WITNESSES- HIGH I
DIDN'T CATCH AND IT'S AWESOME
TO SELF IDENTIFY THINK WAS A
MANUAL WHO'S GOING TO SPEAK
FIRST APOLOGIZE TO- IF YOU WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND INDICATE IF
YOUR PRESENT INDICATE YOUR NAME
AND- YOU MAY PROCEED-
UNLIMITED. REFRESHMENTS WERE
LITTLE MORE THAN HALFWAY-
THROUGH THE AGENDA- THAT THE
LEAD AN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ARE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES
EACH. AND THE TIME IS NOT
TRANSFERABLE WHEN WE GET TO
TELECONFERENCE TESTIMONY IT'S
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IS CASE
MAY BE O WE'LL COME BACK TO-
THE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS OF
THIS TIME. AND LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ALL. ALIVE IN PERSON.
SUPPORT WITNESSING ME SUPPORT
AND SPEAK OF OUR GREAT HERE
INTO THE MICROPHONE THAT'S BOTH
BECAUSE THEIR- I'M SORRY CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES UNIFIED GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS EMMANUEL I'M
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AMANDA I'M LEASES AND I COME TO
YOU TODAY TO PERSONALLY EXPRESS
THE COALITION OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. ONE OF FIVE PROBABILITY
ACT WHICH IDENTIFIES THE
REFORMS PROCESSES THAT HINDER
UPWARD MOBILITY BUT PEOPLE CALL
IN THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. I
AND MANY OF OUR MEMBERS I WORK
WITH THE STATE FROM THREE TO
THIRTY YEARS AND MOST AND THE
MOST DISHEARTENING EXPERIENCES
WE'VE HAD WE'VE SHARED BY THE
INEQUALITY OF PROMOTION THE
MISTREATMENT OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND ALL STATE IMPLEMENT
DEPARTMENTS. CRIED OUT TO OUR
DEPARTMENT EXECUTIVES AS
SECRETARY SO IN THAT CHANGE BUT
OUR CRIES WERE THAT WERE
DEAFENED BY THE LACK OF
INTEREST TO MAKE CHANGES.
REASONS WERE UNKNOWN BUT A
SENSE OF PRIVILEGE EXISTED
WITHIN THEM. THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT OF. NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
WITH AN ANSWER. BUT THEN AFTER
BUT WE ARE STILL WORKING THE
MATH TO GET THE ANSWERS
CORRECTLY. I'M CONSTANTLY
PASSED OVER FOR PROMOTION I DO
NOT SEE ENOUGH OF MY FACES
REPRESENTING THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF OUR LEADERSHIP. I'M NOT
BEING UTILIZED EFFECTIVELY EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE THE MOST
PROVOCATION EXPERIENCES. THESE
ARE SOME OF THE COMMENTS AND
STATEMENTS SEVEN SET BY OUR
MEMBERS AND MANY PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR THE STATE OF FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
INDISCRIMINATE ATTACKS
MOTIVATED BY AMERICANS LONG
LASTING HISTORY OF RACISM.
WHICH IS MORE OFTEN TO IMPLICIT
BIAS IN SOCIETY AND ESPECIALLY
THE WORK FORCE. THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE ANSWERS FOR
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. WE ASK
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO STAND
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY
OUR PROVEN THIS BILL. NOT DOING
SO IS EVIDENCE AS TO WHY IT IS
STILL TAKING THIS FIFTY SEVEN
YEARS TO SOLVE THE SIMPLE
PROBLEM. THIS IS ONE OF MANY
STEPS TO ESTABLISH EQUITY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
HEN NOTICING OTHERS WITNESS
COMING FORWARD. THIS IS ALSO.
ONE OF THETO ME WITNESSES.
SOME MEMBERS THANK YOU. IF YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE
RECORD WE APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. YES SIR-
CHRISTOPHER LOTS AND COALITION
FORCES IMPECCABLE CAL- GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS. THANK YOU
FOR THE TO SPEAK AND- JUST
SUPPORT FOR THE COUPLE MOBILITY
OF TWO TWENTY ONE OR YOU ARE
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
BECAUSE LOTS AND AGAIN THE COLD
FOR JOE. A KIND OF. YOUR
SUPPORT THE TWENTY TWO ONE YOU
IN IS NOT. TO ENSURE OPTIMAL.
AND CONF. RACE INEQUITY IN OUR
STATE BEFORE THE ANY FOR I LIKE
TO SAY HI TO MY MOM. WHOSE LIVE
TODAY AND THAT NOT JUST BECAUSE
I LIKE OF US WANT TO ALMOST. MY
MOM IS ACTUALLY UP PART OF WHAT
WE'RE GONNA ABOUT TO. MY MOM
AND- I REMEMBER WHAT SHE ONCE
TOLD ME THE SHE CHOSE NAME
CHRIS. AND OF MY CIVIL BRIAN
AND THE IT AND ERICA NOT TO
SPEAK HE LIKED NAMES. BUT TO
HIDE OUR- ON JOB. THINK ABOUT
THAT SHE WANTED TO PROTECT ME
AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO
DESCEND FROM U. S. LABOR FROM
THE CURRENT IMPACTS. OF THE
LEGACY AND ENDS UP IN THE
LEGACY OF SLAVERY SEASON. WHICH
INCLUDE EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION. SHE HAD REASON
TO BE WORRIED SHE KNEW WHAT OUR
BEST MOST RECENT EVIDENCE TELLS
US. THAT JOB DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST AFRICAN AMERICANS IT IS
BAD NOW AS IT WAS WHEN SHE WAS
GROWING UP. THAT HALF OF ALL
AFRICAN AMERICAN BORN FOR ARE
STILL POOR BY AGE FORTY AND A
FULL 70% OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN BORN INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS. WILL FALL OUT OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS AS ADULTS. SO SHE
PROTECTED ME. NEVER SAID ANY
MOTHER. ANY FAMILY IN OUR STATE
PARK TO MAKE SUCH A DECISION.
CURRENTLY IS THE POLICY OF OUR
STATE THAT THE COMPOSITION OF
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BE
BROADLY REFLECTIVE OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. INCLUDING
MINORITIES AND WOMEN AND BASED
ON MERIT AND FITNESS. LAST YEAR
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY NINE.
REQUIRES DIVERSITY ON
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE BOARDS
IT'S TIME. FOR OUR STATE THE
STEP UP AS WELL OF. MY BODY IN
FAVOR OF THE TWENTY YOU'RE
MAKING HAVE A TEN. TO MAKE SURE
THAT AT LEAST AS CONCERNED
STATE BORDER TO. NO HAS MAKE
THIS CHOICE BUT MY MOM IS FOR
ME. ALSO HAVE A TO MAKE THAT
THERE IS OVERSIGHT AND MEASURE
APPROACH. THE TWENTY TWENTY YOU
REMEMBER THAT FOR DIFFERENT
BLACK. OFF AMERICAN. TWO THIS.
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO NOW FOR
OUR- A. P. R. BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. BETTER MORE CLEAR DATA
ON THE DIFFERENT NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES MEANS MORE
EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES THAT SAVE
AND IMPROVE. LIVES OCCURRED
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YOU IN MAY THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD THANK YOU- THAT
SHOULD BE THE LIMITED REACH ON
LEAD WITNESSES ON POLICE
SUPPORT WITNESSES BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA ASK THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO- INDICATED
POSITION WHO'S IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IF SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD
AND AT THIS TIME WE'RE MOVING
TO. A NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS KIM NAM
SIGNED WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOR
JUST. EQUITABLE COALITION IN
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH FIVE
UPWARD MOBILITY ACT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU BOTH HI
LARRY THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO STEP UP AND SPEAK. ASSENAGON
WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM A
WE SEE NO WITNESSES THEIR
MODERATOR- WE'RE COMING BACK TO
YOU. A TO Q. UP SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON AB ONE OH FIVE AND
WE'D APPRECIATE KNOWING THE
NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE OH FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE FIVE IN
THE COMMENT Q. AND THAT'S MOVED
UP TO NINE. IN FACT ABOUT WHERE
WE POPPED OFFICE AT NINE NINE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
REMEMBER HIM COMING YEAR OLD
SHARON. WITH THE COALITION
FORCES WILL COVER. SELECTIONS
JACKSON THE BILL. NINE SIXTY SO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS COUNTED JOHN
MUHAMMAD CO CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY THAT THE NATIONAL
ASSEMBLY FOR. AMERICAN SLAVERY
DESCENDANTS LOS ANGELES CHAPTER
AND ALSO NUMBER FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE COALITION FOR JOBS. ARE
IMPECCABLE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WINDS NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANGELA NIRVANA WITH THE
COALITION FOR A JOB. EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THE POOR
MOBILITY AFTER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE YEAH. PORTANTINO THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TO KIA
JONES WITH THE COALITION FOR A
JACKSON EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THE UPWARD MOBILITY ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YES TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TIFFANY QUARREL THE
COALITION FOR A JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE AND
ASK YOU TO PLEASE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE SIXTY NINE YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CAMILLE
MOORE AND I'M A SUPPORTER OF
THE COALITION PROJECT
NEGLIGIBLE CALIFORNIA. AND I
SAT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE
OUTSIDE. THE BOUND MOBILITY
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS SHERRY WITH THE
REPARATIONS COALITION I SUPPORT
THE UPWARD MOBILITY ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE
YES. NINE ONE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER NOW I. NINE RECORDS THE
UPWARD MOBILITY ACT. A TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I'M WITH BLACK
BLACK. ONE ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ASHLEY DILUTES AND- I
AM WITH THE COMMISSION FOR JUST
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THE UP. UPWARD MOBILITY
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE I MEAN
VOTE YES TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT THEY'LL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NINE
ONE NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OPPENHEIMER
KIPLING BUTTER BUT THE COLLEGE
ON FRIDAY JACKSON EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA ARE SUPPORT THE
UPWARD MOBILITY AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PLEASE VOTE YES THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN I
HEARD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ERIC WILLIAMS I'M A SUPPORTER
OF THE COALITION FOR THE JUST
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE WORD BUT THE
UPWARD MOBILITY ACT. NINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CHAD BROWN I'M WITH
THE COALITION FOR A JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE UPWARD MOBILITY
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLEASE
VOTE YES TO SUPPORT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS EVAN MINTON LEGISLATIVE FOR
PROGRESS WE'RE INTO COURT AND
AB ONE ZERO FIVE THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU.
MODERATOR IN. THE WILL COME
BACK BECAUSE NOW TO. OPPOSITION
AND GO THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON RECORD. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM WAS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. C. NONE BUT WILL CHECK
YOUR FULL ROOM. THERE IS NO ONE
THERE TO TESTIFY THE MODERATOR
TO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ONE AND IF SO
HOW MANY TEETH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCEAGAIN. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ONE OH FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN SIR. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS WE DO HAVE ONE PARTY IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU.
TO BE
JUST A MOMENT. NINE ONE SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MAXIMUM
MARGINAL I LIVE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AB
ONE OFFLINE. I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SOVIET UNION
REGIONALES NAME WAS A COUNTRY
WITH. I'M SORRY. YOU DO DID
THOUGH WE ARE ALLOWED TO DO
YOUR NAME FIVE OF ANY AT EUROPE
THANK YOU FOR BEING ON THE
LINE. PRETREATED OKAY. THE
MARTYRS A CONCLU THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE TALK OVERSIGHT.
IT DOES THERE ARE NO FURTHER
AND SHE'S OKAY GREAT.THANK YOU
AND WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME OF SEEN
NONE WILL OFFER THE AUTHORED
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE. OKAY AGAIN
GERMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
WORKING WITH US I THINK THAT IT
HAS. MADE IT A STRONGER BILL-
AND A LOT OF RESPECTS AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR- WORK ON THIS BILL WITH
ADMINISTRATION. AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING ALL THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY MAY HAVE OR
ADDITIONAL ISSUES THEY THINK
ARE IMPERATIVE SO. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO KEEPING A LIFELINE
TO YOUR COMMITTEE AS WELL SO I
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MEMBER AND WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS TO WORK. WITH THE
DELIVER THE EXITING STAFF ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND WE HEARD YOU
EARLIER INDICATE THAT YOU ARE.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. SO
WITH THAT WE CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. MOVED BY SEN DRAW. HERE
S. CONSULTANT TO STATE THE
MOTION AND- TAKE THE ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COURTESY HI WHERE
DOES THE AYE ULTRABOOK. THE
RESTAURANT HI THE REST SO I
LAYERED. I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
OKAY- THE FOOD WAS SERVED FOR
HER TWO ZERO WITH ONE NOT
ROUTINE AND THAT MEANS BILLS UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY IF. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE- OURSELVES FOR THE OUT OF
ORDER ONE MORE TIME THERE'S NO
OBJECTION FROM THE COMMITTEES-
BY AGREEMENT OF THE AUTHOR'S-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS- WILL GO
AHEAD OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOMENT
SO THAT MEANS WE'RE GONNA HEAR
AB ONE OH FOUR ONE. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AT TEN
FORTY ONE WILL EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY MEMBER FOR
PURPOSES OF FAMILY CAREGIVING
AND SICK LEAVE TO ALLOW WORKERS
TO TAKE TIME OFF TO CARE FOR
QUITE A DESIGNATED PERSON. THIS
COULD INCLUDE A FRIEND OR
PARTNER. WHO CAN PROVE THAT
THEIR- THEIR DEPENDENCY WITH A
DOCTOR'S NOTE. TO THE MAJORITY
OF HOUSEHOLDS APART FROM THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY MODEL OF A
MARRIED COUPLE WITH THEIR
BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN. AND SAID
THIS FAMILIES INCLUDE LOVED
ONES WHO AREN'T BIOLOGICALLY OR
LEGALLY RELATED DATA FROM THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY CENSUS
BUREAU SHOWS THAT EIGHTEEN
POINT 4% OF AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS. FOLLOW THE
TRADITIONAL FAMILY STRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIA FAMILY LEAVE LAWS
CONTINUE TO REFLECT OUTDATED
TRADITIONAL FAMILY MODELS ONLY
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES TO TAKE.
TIME OFF TO CARE FOR NEARLY TO
FIND MY FAMILY MEMBERS. THIS
POLICY GAP CERTAINLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY- IMPACTS THE
LGBT Q. I COMMUNITY. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE FOURTH LARGEST LGBTQ I
POPULATION THE U. S. MANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY DO
NOT HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THEIR BIOLOGICAL RELATIVES.
THERE FOR THEIR LIVES AND LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE BIOLOGICAL
SUPPORT AND RELY ON THEIR
CHOSEN FAMILY INSTEAD. ANOTHER
STUDY FOUND THAT THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF MULTI
GENERATIONAL FAMILIES CAN BE
FOUND IN NEW YORK AND LOS
ANGELES. TO THE MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKETS IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON COMMON FOR RESIDENTS
TO BE LIVING WITH COUSINS
UNCLES AND OTHER RELATIVES NOT
COVERED BY EXISTING LEAVE LAWS.
SPECIFICALLY DURING COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT PRECEDENT FOR
EXPANDING OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS AND STATE
AND LOCAL LAW AND REALLY
MODERNIZING OUR LANGUAGE AND
ENSURING THAT WE DON'T HAVE
POLICIES THAT. ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACT CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
ORGAN CONNECTICUT NEW JERSEY IN
COLORADO EIGHT LOCALITIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES HAVE
SIMPLY PASSED SIMILAR SICK LAWS
THAT COVER CHOSEN FAMILY. IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO JOIN
THESE OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS HAVE. THE
RIGHT TO BE THERE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES WHEN NEEDED
REGARDLESS OF THEIR BLOOD OR
LEGAL RELATIONSHIP. WITH ME
HERE TO REFILL TESTIFIES
JESSICA STENDER REPRESENT EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. AND YOUR BED
CERVANTES. OKAY YOU JESSICA
STANDARD MAY PRESS IF OF. I AM
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JESSICA STENDER AND I AM SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE
AND PUBLIC POLICY EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND WE'RE ACROSS
PROUD CO SPONSOR EIGHTY TEN
TWENTY ONE. AND YOU'VE HEARD
THE CURRENTLY LAWS COME INTO
PLAY TO TAKE TIME OFF WORK TO
CARE FOR A SICK FAMILY MEMBER
THE CALIFORNIA CAN ONLY TAKE
LEADER CERTAIN LIMITED FAMILY
MEMBERS OFTEN DOESN'T MEET
THEIR NEEDS. AB TEN FORTY ONE
PROVIDER STRAIGHT FOURTEEN
SHORELINE BY UPDATING THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY MEMBER FOR
PURPOSES OF CARE GIVINGAND
QUICKLY TO ALLOW WORKERS TO
CARE FOR A DESIGNATED PERSON
IDENTIFIED AT THE TIME OF THEIR
LEAVE REQUESTS. IMPORTANTLY
EMPLOYERS MAY LIMIT WORKERS TO
ONLY ONE DESIGNATED PERSON
EVERY TWELVE MONTHS AND THERE'S
JUST TWO OTHER IMPORTANT THING
THAT LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT ABOUT
THE BILL. FIRST THE BILL DOES
NOT CREATE ANY NEW OR
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF LEAD TIME
IT SIMPLY ALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO
USE THEIR EXISTING PAID SICK OR
FAMILY LEAVE UNDER EXISTING LAW
TO CARE FOR THE LOVED ONES WHO
MOST DEPEND ON THEM TO MAKE
THEIR FAMILY. SECOND THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO TAKE THIS LEAVE A
SMALL BUT FOR THOSE PEOPLE
BELIEVE IS LIFE CHANGING THE
EDT REPORT THAT LESS THAN POINT
3% OF ALL PAID FAMILY LEAVE
CLEAN ARE TO CARE FOR AN
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER POINT 3%
IS NOT A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
BUSINESS. EMPLOY WHO NEEDED FOR
IN HIS CAR. AND LIFE MANY. LAST
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO HIGH. THE
CALIFORNIA ALREADY. ON THIS
ISSUE. YOU'VE HEARD THE FEDERAL.
SIXTY EIGHT AND EIGHT LOCALITY.
INCLUDING LA HAVE ARE ADOPTED A
MARKSMAN THAT OF FAN HAVE YOU
THOUGHT. IN ANYWAY WE ARE A
LEADER N LGBTQ AYE RIGHT.
HOWEVER IN THIS AREA WE LIVE
BEHIND. TO STAND BY OUR VALUES
OF EQUITY AND INCLUSION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU A GREAT JOB ON
THE TWO MINUTES- A BET
CERVANTES. ARE YOU BUILD HAS
WORKED. YES IN HERE. GOOD
EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ABOUT AB
TEN FORTY ONE THE CHOSEN FAMILY
BELL MY NAME IS ABOUT TO RUN
HAS I'M A RESIDENT OF ORANGE
COUNTY. ANIMAL AND CHAIR FOR
THE LGBTQ CENTER OC. AS A
VOLUNTEER FOR THE FINER WE HOLD
THE FUNDS GIVING ABOUT EACH
YEAR. AT THE TIME TO OPEN OUR
DOORS AND ALLOW FOLKS TO ENJOY
A MEAL MUSIC. GAMES AND ABILITY
HELPS WONDERFUL CONVERSATIONS.
WHEN YOU'RE NOT A WOMAN WHO WAS
SITTING WITH A YOUNG MAN WHO
HAD BEEN ASKED TO LEAVE AT HOME.
YOUR SEXUAL ORIENTATION SHE WAS
DOING EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO
HELP HIM GET INTO COLLEGE. MAKE
SURE YOU INSPIRED. THAT HAVE
SHELTER AND HELP HIM WITH HIS
MEDICAL ISSUES. SHE WAS TRULY
DOING EVERYTHING FOR HIM A
MOMENT TO. HOWEVER SINCE HE WAS
ALREADY MENTAL WHEN SHE BECAME
IS COMES IN MY- OUR CURRENT
LAWS NOT PART. OUR SHE'D TAKE
TIME OFF FROM. TO HELP WITH
MEDICAL ISSUES. AB TEN. FORTY
ONE. WHAT ALSO PROTECT PEOPLE
LIKE MY EIGHT YEAR OLD MOTHER.
WAS ADMITTED TO A LOCAL
HOSPITAL FOR COMPLICATIONS FROM
CO THAT IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MANY YEARS TAKES
HER TO HER DOCTOR APPOINTMENTS
TAKES OUR GROCERY SHOPPING.
EXCEPT FOR MEDICATION REALLY
DOES EVERYTHING OUTSIDE DO.
HELLO THEY'RE NOT MARRIED. MY
MOTHER'S PARTNER WAS ADVISED
SHE COULD TAKE TIME OFF FROM
WORK TO CARE FOR HER WHEN SHE
LEFT THE HOSPITAL- THEY WOULD
NOT COMPENSATE HIM AND THEY
COULD NOT GUARANTEE JOB KNOW
WHEN YOU. I WONDER SURE ONE
OTHER WITH TODAY. IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WHEN THERE WAS NO
FMLA MY SIX REAL WE COULD FILE
SPENT TWO WEEKS NOW AND I SEE
YOU. I WAS LUCKY THAT MY WORK
ALLOWED ME TO SPEND EVERY
MOMENT OF HER STAY WITH HER.
BUT YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE
LUCKY WHEN YOUR FAMILY MEMBER
IS STILL VERY SICK. REALLY THAT
ARE NOT RECOGNIZED BY THE LAW.
ARE NO LESS COMMITTED. ARE
MEANINGFUL. CHOSEN FAMILY IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT. AND
SOMETIMES A LIFESAVING. WHEN IT
COMES TO THOSE WHO ARE PART OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY. AND HAD TO
FIND LOVE. AND ACCEPTANCE FROM
OTHER PEOPLE. BECAUSE THEIR OWN
FAMILIES REJECTED NOT. HI AB
TEN FORTY ONE TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES LIKE MINE ARE
REFLECTED NOT A LOT. OKAY THANK
YOU IS THE SERVICE WELCOME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOR ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE PRESENT
WHO WISH TO SPEAK ON AB TEN
FORTY ONE. OBSCENE NO ONE STEP
FORWARD WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW
ROOM TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO
ONE THERE IS NO ONE THERE TO
TESTIFY WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. AND ASK HER TO QUEUE
UP SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS ON AB
TEN FORTY ONE AM PLEASE
INDICATE THE NUMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN FORTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IN CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE EIGHT-
MAKE TEN ELEVEN AND GROWING IN
THE SUPPORT QUEUE. NINE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ARE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA. BOB
THERE'S A BIT STYLE WE STRONGLY
URGES THE COURT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACCORDING
MARK NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
MINUS URBAN. SURE THERE'S NO
ONE THERE'S ONE THERE SO FAR.
OUR CRUPI. MODERATOR IF YOU
NEED TO MOVE ON. MY ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE S OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE SOVIET POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND FACULTY COUNSELLORS
AND STAFF MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NET ONE EIGHTY FOUR
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SEND THEM
BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE COURT. NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
WHEN ANYTHING IN A WHILE HARM
WELL ON BEHALF OF A. R. P.
CALIFORNIA THREE POINT THREE
ONE ZERO FOUR ONE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND- REPORT THANK
YOU. NINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAROLINA FOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU CAL ACTION IN SUPPORT.
NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JAM PACKED WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
TRANSPORT. NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY ONE. NINE ONE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING JULIA PARISH AT
LEGAL AID AT WORK PROUD OF
COSPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS KATIE WATER
STRESS OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION WE ARE
PROUD COULD PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF AB TEN FORTY ONE. ONE ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS POLITICALLY FIGARO AND
I'M THE CHAIR OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY QUALITY COALITION AND
WE'RE CALLING TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY'S LGBTQ
CLASSCOMMUNITY THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- WILL COME BACK. INTO
THE SAME PROCESS WITH
OPPOSITION- WE DO NOT HAVE OR
WE DO HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITH THE SIPO JURIES ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE YOU
ARE. WELCOME TO TESTIFY AT THIS
TIME HI. A GOOD EVENING MISTER
TURN MEMBERS ACTUALLY HOFFMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
FORTY ONE I DO WANT TO START BY
THINKING THE AUTHOR- IN THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THAT
WERE TAKEN EARLIER IN THE
SESSION AND THAT REMOVES A
JOCULAR TAG FROM THE BILL.
HOWEVER OURS US IN OUR
COALITION MUST REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THIS TIME I'M JUST DUE TO
THE OTHER LEAVE EXPANSIONS AND
NEW LEAVE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PLACED ON SMALL BUSINESS
OVER THE PAST YEAR DURING THE
PANDEMIC. INCLUDING TWO ROUNDS
OF KOBE PAID SICK LEAVE
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHTS ACT THAT AFFORDS
TWELVE WEEKS OF LEAVE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES WE JUST FIVE
EMPLOYEES AND THE LEAVING OF
THE CARILLO SHOT MARGIN SEE
REGULATION. SO WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
AT THIS TIME WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TAKE IN OPPOSITION
POSITION OF SO PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. C. NINE WILL TO THE
FOUR. IF ARE ANY WITH. THIRTY
TESTIFY- HEARING NONE- WILL
MOVE ON TO THE MODERATOR IN AS
THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
AB TEN FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN FORTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO PARTIES IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. SORRY. ONE NINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
SURE NUMBERS PERFORMED ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND- HI THIS IS EVAN MINTON
WITH VOICES FOR PROGRESS I
APOLOGIZE I THOUGHT I WAS IN
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR PROGRESS CAN SENSE OF
BUSINESS LEADERS BUSINESS
OWNERS AND ENTREPRENEURS. WE
HAVE A PRIORITY SUPPORT
POSITION ON THIS BILL. ANYONE
ELSE MODERN. ONE MOMENT FAR
LEFT PARTY. ONE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU THE CONCLUDES OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SO COMPACT COMMITTEE-
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
CENTER DROUGHT SO I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND ALSO THANK THE AUTHOR
WOODS- QUITE SURPRISING TO ME
IS. THE FAMILY VALUES THAT WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT. AND WE HEAR
ABOUT ALL THE SERVICES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR FAMILIES THAT YOU
KNOW HAVE MISSED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE CARE OF ONE
ANOTHER. THIS IS ABOUT UNPAID-
THIS IS ABOUT UNPAID LEAVE SO
HERE YOU HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER.
OR A- THE NONTRADITIONAL
FELLING FAMILY MEMBER WANTING
TO TAKE CARE WHY BE THE CARE
GIVER THAT'S NEEDED AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME. AND WILLING TO
GIVE UP THEIR SALARY IN ORDER
TO DO THAT THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO THEM AND YET WE WOULD
NOT PROTECT THEM UNDER THEIR
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT.
FLOOR TO TAKE A COUPLE OF SIX
PAID SICK DAYS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT IT IS RIGHT UHHUH. SO I-
I'M REALLY GLAD YOU'RE YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS UP AND I WOULD
REALLY URGE THAT- WHOEVER'S ALL
THE LIST OF. OF THE OPPOSITION
WOULD. LOOK LIKE- EMPLOYERS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS TO RETHINK THEIR
POSITION AND TO ALLOW THESE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE WILLING TO
GIVE UP AND SACRIFICE SO MUCH.
JUST THE TIME OFF THAT'S ALL
WE'RE ASKING FOR SO PRECIADO
THANK YOU YOU REMEMBER SO
CENTER ALERT. YEP FROM
INTERESTINGLY- ARE IN OUR FLOOR
DEBATE EARLIER TODAY- I TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT I HEADED AN
AIDS SERVICE AGENCY THIRTY
YEARS AGO RIGHT NOW. AND THAT
THERE WERE. OUR FAMILIES THAT
WERE BIOLOGICALLY RATE RELATED
BUT THERE WERE NO RIGHTS OF THE
SPOUSES AND THAT THEY WOULD
COME INTO TOWN. AND TAKE HALF A
HOUSE WHEN SOMEBODY PASSED AWAY
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE STRANGE
THEY WOULD KEEP THE PARTNER
FROM VISITING IN THE HOSPITAL.
THERE WERE INCREDIBLE FUNCTION
WHAT WE DID IS WE AS A
GOVERNMENT ADMINISTERED PEOPLE
RECOGNIZED WHAT WAS LACKING IN
THAT AN EXTENDED PROTECTIONS
AND MADE SURE THAT THINGS LIKE
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN WITHIN
THAT MORE TRADITIONAL LEGAL
FRAMEWORK OF MARRIAGE OR OR TAX
MEANT. AND I THINK THAT WHILE
THAT WAS CONTROVERSIAL- OF
MOVIE IT WAS RECOGNIZED ALSO ON
THE FLOOR THAT NOW THERE'S EVEN
A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS
SUPPORT MARRIAGE EQUALITY AND A
I THINK THAT THE COUNTRY MOVED
TO WHERE THE JUSTICE WAS AND
WHERE THE PEOPLE WERE IN THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS. WHAT I THINK
THIS BILL DOES IS TAKE THE NEXT
STEP BECAUSE THERE ARE EXACTLY.
THOSE KIND OF RELATIONSHIPS
THAT MIGHT BE NONTRADITIONAL
BUT ARE REAL AND I HAD ONE IN
MY FAMILY WHERE. MY BROTHER AND
HIS PARTNER'S BEST FRIEND FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THE DAY
ENDED UP BEING HIS CARE GIVERS
AT THE END AND DOING MANY OTHER
THINGS AND WHILE THEY WERE
PRIVILEGED IN A WAY THAT THEY
DIDN'T. HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH
THEY WERE IN A SITUATION THAT
THIS BILL COVERS. ARE THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
TAKE LEAVE WHEN THEY WERE GOING
TO HELP THAT PERSON TO THE LAST
MONTHS AND WEEKS OF HIS LIFE.
AND SO V. E. R. I GET THAT
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WOULD BE ABUSED BUT
ACTUALLY. AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES SAID IT'S A SMALL
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS AND IT IS
REALLY MOVING TOWARD WHERE THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION REALLY
IS AND SO- HIGHS ARE ARE.
SALUTE TO A PERSON FOR BRINGING
AT A RECOGNIZED THE CONCERNS IN
THE OPPOSITION BUT I THINK JUST
AS WE MOVED PAST AND UNDERSTOOD
THE VALIDITY OF PASSED CHANGES
WE'VE MADE. WE WILL FEEL THAT
WAY ABOUT THIS ONE AFTER THE
LAWN SANTEN AND GOES INTO SO
ARE. WILL BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. THE NEW. YORK I
CLEARLY SEE IN YOUR BLUE SPOT
TODAY. BAD I I'D ACTUALLY DONE
DECEMBER MEMBER WICKS A I DON'T
HAVE MUCH TO ADD TO MY CAR. BOB
I CAN YOU FOR BEING BILL FOR
THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF LINE
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUAL POLICIES-
AND I WOULD BE GRATEFUL TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD SHOULD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WITH A USER
NEWMAN APPROACH TO TELL YOU
WHEN WE STARTED UP THIS
COMMITTEE THAT I ALMOST NEVER
LOOKED TO MY RIGHT. I DON'T
HAVE IT. C. FIVE. I HAVE A
FEELING YOU'RE GONNA BREAK THAT
THAT OF MINE. OF ANYBODY-
REASON ALL OF US SIT ON THE
SIDE OF. I GOT LEFT WITH THE-
THE BAD SPOT HERE. TO THE
STREET MILL I APOLOGIZE OF BACK
TO THE AUTHOR- IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE HIS- WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN IS A CO
AUTHOR APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS-
OVER HERE AS WELL YOU KNOW AND
WE CELEBRATED- PRIDE TODAY ON
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY AS
WELL- WHICH IS ALWAYS AN
UPLIFTING MOMENT WHERE WE BOTH
REFLECT ON OUR HISTORY HOW FAR
WE'VE GONE BUT THEN ALSO WE
NEED TO REALIZE WHERE WE ALSO
NEED TO GO- AND THAT OUR
POLICIES NEED TO IN FACT MATCH
OUR VALUES AS YOU SAID- I THINK
THIS BILL IS. A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO DO THAT- IT
HELPS HER LGBT Q. I COMMUNITY
BUT ALSO I'VE HAD COLLEAGUES
WHO COME UP TO ME AND SAID YOU
KNOW I HAVE A PARTNER WE'RE NOT
MARRIED THIS BILL ACTUALLY HELP
ME AS WELL THEY'RE NOT LGBT Q.
SO IT'S OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL.
TO YOUR POINT- HAVE EMOTIONAL
CONNECTIONS AND THIS IS OUR
CHOSEN FAMILY AND MORE MORE
PEOPLE ARE LIVING WITH CHOSEN
FAMILY SO JUST WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
OKAY THANK YOU SOME MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND- CENTER DRAWS WHO I BELIEVE
OFFERED THE- THE MOTION
EARLIER. AND SO WE WILL MOVE.
TO THE CONSULTANT FOR THE ROLL
CALL NOW. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
COURTESY HI. OR DOES THE I OR
CHOI BOGUE. NO TROUBLE NO THE
RESTAURANT. RESO I'D LAYERED HI
THERE I NEWMAN ALL RIGHT.
NEWMAN I. THREE FOUR ONE WHO'S
BILLS OUT THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN- DEFERRED EARLIER
SO IF YOU'RE LISTENING WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING BACK TO WHAT WAS
THE NINTH ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
FOR THOSE FOLLOWING AN ACTUAL
GENDER AND THIS IS AB THREE
THIRTY FOUR. OF WELCOME IN THE
RADIATOR YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO PRESENT THANK YOU SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD
MELANOMA I KNOW HOW SCARY THAT
DIAGNOSIS CAN BE THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE REALLY HITS HOME FOR ME
AB THREE THIRTY FOUR WILL
ESTABLISH A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION OF SKIN CANCER
DEVELOPED BY CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE OFFICERS. IN PARK
RANGERS IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
EXCESSIVE EXPOSURE TO THE SUN
DURING THEIR EMPLOYMENT IT
WOULD REMOVE UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE OFFICERS AND PARK
RANGERS TO QUALIFY FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH SKIN CANCER AND
WOULD REDUCE THE DEPARTMENT'S
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE AND PARKS AND
RECREATION'S EFFORTS TO
INITIATE AND COMPLETE A WORKERS
COMPENSATION INVESTIGATION ON
THE CLAIMS. DOUG HAWKINS
RETIRED FISH AND WILDLIFE
ASSISTANT CHIEF WAS HAD TO HAVE
THREE SKIN CANCER SURGERIES
EXPLAINS THAT IS SET CITY OF
THIS BILL WELL HE WRITES AND I
QUOTE SKIN CANCER WAS ALWAYS A
CONCERN TO ME BOTH DURING AND
AFTER MY THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
WARNING ESPECIALLY HAVING SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS DAYS AND WEEKS
AT SEA ON PATROL. I REGULARLY
APPLIED SUNBLOCK AT THE SURE
AMOUNT OF TIME SPENT IN THE SUN
JUST SEEMS TO OVERWHELM EFFORTS
TO KEEP SKIN CANCER AT BAY AS
YOU KNOW WARDENS HIKE SWEAT AND
OPERATE A VERY DIRTY
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ENDLESS HOURS
AS A RESULT MOST CAN BLOCK
CREAMS SEEM TO HAVE LITTLE
CHANCE OF REMAINING IN PLACE
THROUGHOUT A PATROL AND QUOTE.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT GOOD DATA
IS ANYTIME A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION IS BEING DISCUSSED
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY I
REQUESTED A COMMISSION ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION CHEESE WORK STUDY
ON THE PREVALENCE OF WORKERS.
COMP CLAIMS FOR SKIN CANCER
FROM WILD I OFFICERS PARK RAIN.
AND WHAT THE PER. OF ACCEPTED
PERSISTED I CLAIMS WERE AND HOW
EXCESSIVE SKIN EXPOSURE MAY
INCREASE THE INCIDENCE OF SKIN
CANCER AMONGTHESE PARTICULAR.
WORKERS UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL
KNOW HOW LAST YEAR TURNED OUT
WITH THE PANDEMIC AND SO THE
STUDY HAS BEEN DELAYED. BUT NOT
FORGOTTEN MY OFFICE HAS SPOKEN
TO THE DIRECTOR OF CHISWICK
SEVERAL TIMES AND HE HAS
ASSURED US THAT THE STUDIES A
PRIORITY FOR THEM. THAT THEY
ARE DOING THEIR BEST TO
COMPLETE IT IN DUE TIME.
HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE NEXT
MONTH. OR TWO SO I'M COMMITTING
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FOR TODAY
THAT I WILL NOT MOVE IT OUT OF
THE SENATE WITHOUT THAT STUDY.
BEING COMPLETED AND IN HAND I
TO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ALL THE MOVING FORWARD WITH
A BILL THAT THE SCIENCE BACKS
UP SO THANK YOU. AND I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY FIGURE WITHIN
THE LOCAL TO THE LEAD SPORT
WITNESS LAUREN NIXON. IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS LAUREN NIXON SHOEMAKER I'M A
SUPERVISOR IN STATE PARK EACH
OFFICER A CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS. MELANOMA SURVIVOR AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR AB THREE THREE
FOUR. ASIAN WILDLIFE WARDENS
AND STATE PARK OFFICER PEACE
OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO SPEND
LONG SHIPS EXPLODING BERMAN TO
ALMOND INCLUDING UNRELENTING
HEAT OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS THEY
WERE DESERVE BETTER. ABOUT OF
ALL PRESUMPTION AB THREE YEARS
FOR PROVIDES I'M A SUPERVISOR A
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS THAT
HAVE BEEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
IN A PEACE OFFICER CAPACITY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. IN
JULY OF TWENTY FOURTEEN I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY AND PLEASURE OF
MEETING OFFICER BLACK BOTTOM
PLATE WITH A DEDICATED OFFICER
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE TO MANY
MORE IMPORTANTLY HERE. THE
FATHER HUSBAND AND SON. I CAN
AMOUNT. THE OF A- SONICS DURING
THE COURSE OF THE- CLICK APPLY
FOR COVER FROM TOP. WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM AND WAS
DENIED. BREAK APPEALED THE
DENIAL ON JANUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BLAKE DIED AS A
RESULT OF MELANOMA WITHOUT
KNOWING THE FINE YOU. IN LATE
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
SAME WEEK MY FRIEND AND FELLOW
STATE PARK THESE OFFICERS.
TRAVELED FROM ACROSS THE STATE
TO PARTICIPATE AN HONOR AND
COLOR GUARDS WICKS CLICK ON A
MEMORIAL SERVICE. I RECEIVED MY
MELANOMA DIAGNOSIS AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY SEVEN. I HAD A
REGULAR MALL ON MY LEFT BICEP
REMOVED BY DERMATOLOGISTS. I'LL
JUST CONFIRMED A PRODUCTIVE
STAGE ONE MELANOMA DIAGNOSTICS
TREATMENT FOR MY CANCER WHAT
THE MARGIN ON MOBILE AND
TECHNOLOGY NODE BIOPSY A LARGE
SCAR ON MY OUTER BICEPS THE
PHYSICAL REMINDER OF MY CANCER.
PSYCHOLOGICAL REMINDERS OF THE
HIGHER RISK FOR REOCCURRENCE OR
SPREAD- AND DESCRIBE. I
INCREASING THE COVERAGE WERE
RESPONDED TO WITH QUOTE RANGERS
ARE NOT INCLUDED. IF I'D BEEN A
LIFE GUARD EMPLOYED BY MY
DEPARTMENT. THE PRESUMPTION
WOULD HAVE EXISTED. MY
EXPERIENCE IS ONE OF MANY FOR
WARRANTED RANGERS WHO WORK TO
PROTECT THE BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND NATURAL OR
HISTORIC LANDSCAPES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
REFLECTED IN THE EVIDENCE
PRESENTED AND DOCUMENTATION
PROVIDED AB THREE THREE FOUR
TECHNOLOGY IS THE PRESUMPTION.
MORDINGTON RANGERS ENCOUNTER
WITHIN THE REQUIREMENTS OF OUR
EMPLOYMENT. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT WILDLIFE OFFICERS AND
PARK RANGERS ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY A DENNY STEPHENSON
ARE YOU WILLING TO TESTIFY. YES
I'M HERE SIR ALL RIGHT PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. WELL THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME UP BY
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A DANNY
STEVENSON AND I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
WARDEN SUPERVISOR THE MANDARINS
EDUCATION WHAT YOU'RE
SPONSORING THE AB THIRTY THREE
FOUR. WE ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE WARDEN ALLEN ONE GARDEN
CORRECT CONTRACT CONTRACTED
MELANOMA DUE TO EXCESSIVE.
OCCUPATIONAL FUND EXPOSURE OVER
THE COURSE OF HIS CAREER. AFTER
CONTRACTING IN YOUR LIFE FOR
COVERAGE FROM CALIFORNIA'S
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM IN
ITS CLAIM OF THE NIGHT. SHE HAD
TO SEE THE GAME COVERAGE WHILE
FIGHTING FOR THE LIFE. YOU KNOW
CAN WE WILL SUCCESSFUL IN THE
LAWSUIT ALTHOUGH THE STRESS THE
LEGAL PROCESS WITH OVERWHELMING
WHILE TRYING TO MANAGE THE
DISEASE. ALLEN WAITED JUST LONG
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT SUCCESSFUL
SO YOU WILL PROVIDE BETTER
BENEFITS TO HIS WIFE AND HIS
TWO KIDS JUST BEFORE HE PASSED
AWAY. SIMILAR CIRCA. OR ALSO IN
KERN ENCOUNTERED FOR A STATE
PARK RANGER THAT SUFFERED
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS WITH
WORKERS COMP. WHICH IS MISTER
BOND. I AM A CAPTAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND I ALSO BEEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS. DURING MY TIME AT YOUR
WORKSTATION WHILE BUT I HAVE
HAD TWO BIGELOW CARCINOMAS
REMOVED FROM. MY FACE AND LEFT
ARM. DESPITE BEST EFFORTS TO
REGIONALLY APPLY SUNSCREEN AND
WEAR LONG SLEEVE ENHANCE. AND
TAKE OTHER PRECAUTIONS SEVERAL
PUBLISHED STUDIES LIKE MINE AND
MORE NOW ON WINE GARDENS IS
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT AS A
RESULT. OF OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE TO THE SUN. EVERY
POLICE OFFICER DEPUTY SHERIFF
IN CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA IS
COVERED BY LABOR CODE THIRTY TO
TWELVE POINT ONE WHICH STATE IN
SHORT THANK YOU CANCER
INCLUDING SKIN CANCER. THAT
DEVELOPS FOR MANIFESTED ITSELF
DURING A PERIOD IN WHICH THEY
WERE EXPOSED WALL IN THE
SERVICE OF THEIR AGENCY TO A
KNOWN CARCINOGEN IN THE RESULT
OF OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURE TO
THAT CARCINOGEN. WE ARE MAKING
AMERIQUEST INCLUDE INCLUDE OUR
OFFICERS IN RANGERS IN THE SKIN
CANCER PRESUMPTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN FOR HIS SUPPORT AND WE
URGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT GAME
WARDENS AND PARK RANGERS BY
VOTING YES ON THE COMPARTEN
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON. SORRY THE CREW
TO AND- WE HAVE ELSE WISH TO
SPEAK IN A SUPPORT FOR HIM TO
GET A SUPPORT POSITION PLEASE
PURCELL THANK YOU EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
MY NAME IS JENNIFER FEARING AND
I'M HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE FOUR
AND A HALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE OFFICERS FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. ASSENAGON
WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO
TESTIFY- MODERATOR A COULD YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE THIRTY FOUR AND
PLEASE INDICATE THE NUMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO. COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THREE THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE
FOUR PARTIES IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. CAN LINE. ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS GEORGE
STRUBLE I'M A CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE OFFICER ASSISTANT
CHIEF AND I'VE FOUGHT SKIN
CANCER ON THREE OCCASIONS
MYSELF I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. MY MODEL FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GERMAN MEMBERS OF YOUR GROUP
AND ON THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIARIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION ALSO RETIRED
GAME WARDEN WITH THIRTY TWO
YEARS TO THE SERVICE ALSO HAD
NUMEROUS- PATIENTS CELLS
REMOVED FROM MY STATION ARMS WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE FOUR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU SOME OF
MY MULLIN FOR SPONSORING THIS
BILL. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTY
WURSTER I'M AN ASSISTANT CHIEF
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE. I MYSELF
I'VE FOUGHT ENCOUNTER AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO REPRESENTING THE
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. THREE THREE
FOUR. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR- WILL REPEAT THE
PROCESS FOR A POSITION AT THIS
TIME ALTHOUGH THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WORSE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION POSITION OF
SO PLEASE SUPPORT. US SEEN NO
ONE CHECKED THE OVERFLOW ROOM
ADDITIONAL ON THERE TO TESTIFY
MODERATOR ALREADY BACK TO YOU
IN- WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO. THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THIRTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND I'M THE STAR FROM A RIGHT.
WELL NOW I FEEL OBLIGATED TO
PARTICIPATE. ASSEMBLY EMBER
MULLIN I DO APPRECIATE THIS
BILL I HAD A COLLEAGUE WHOSE
HUSBAND WAS NOT ONLY A
FIREFIGHTER BUT I'M A VOLUNTEER
PARK. RANGERS WHO GOT A
MELANOMA BEHIND HIS EAR- AND
DID NOT FIND IT TOO MUCH TOO
LATE PASSED WHY SHOULD PREACHER
YOU BRING THIS BILL. LED
SUPPORTED LIKE TO MOVE IT. OUT
WHEN THE TIMES APPROPRIATE.
BIRDS ARE NEWMAN THE- HAS
OFFERED A MOTION ON THE BILL
WILL MOVE TO MY LEFT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS CENTER
ALERT I JUST MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT SINCE I HAD FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND PARKS IN MY
PORTFOLIO FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
ALWAYS INTERESTING HAVING SPENT
TIME THIS VERY WEEKEND WITH
PARK RANGERS AND- FISH AND
WILDLIFE EMPLOYEES OUTSIDE. THE
ARE. IT'S OBVIOUS WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY STATE PARKS
IN THE OUTSIDE BUT I THINK A
LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE THAT MANY OF THE-
WILDLIFE OFFICERS FORMERLY
KNOWN AS GAME WARDENS- WORK OUT
OF THEIR HOUSES. THEY HAVE A
CAR SIGNED THERE AND IT'S NOT
LIKE THEY GO TO AN OFFICE OR GO
TO AN INSIDE SPACE IN ANY WAY
THEY ARE JUST OUTSIDE IN EVERY
BIT OF THEIR- WORK. IN
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE IN
THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT- I MEAN
THEY WERE JUST. ON THE WATER ON
THE COAST. ARE JUST. ALMOST ALL
THE TIME AND SO WE ARE
EXPECTING THEM TO BE IN THE
ELEMENTS IN A WAY THAT IT IS
HARD TO PROTECT AND I THINK THE
TESTIMONY WE HAVE SHOWN WHAT
THE RESULTS OR FROM THAT. SO I
THINK THIS IS A BILL THAT MAKES
SENSE I MEAN TO BE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU INSERTED
ROWS OF I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR- I WAS MORE.
FAMILIAR WITH GENERALLY
SPEAKING WITH CONSTRUCTION.
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY SPEND
THEIR- AS EVERYTHING DAY IS YOU
MENTIONED- BUT I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROSER WOULD
SONORA NO THE REQUESTED TO BE
RECOGNIZED HERE ON THE DAIS
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE OF
SOME MEMBER STATES SHARE THINGS
STAFF AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS AND APPRECIATE- THE-
EXPERIENCE OF FORMER SECRETARY
LAYERED- WHO KNOWS THESE ISSUES
WELL APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
AND- AS- THREE THANK YOU IN
CENTER NEWMAN IT OFFERED THE
MOTION SO WE'LL GO STRAIGHT TO
THE CONSOLE FOR THE ROLL CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI. BUT AS THE I. R.
CHOI BOGUE HI BUT SHOVEL GUY.
WRESTLE THE REST I LAYERED AYE
LAYERED AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN AYE IT'S UNANIMOUS OF
BILLS OUT THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO AUTHORED TODAY HE IS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALAS EIGHTY
SIX WELCOME TO YOU. CAN YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY- ON
THE FIRST SIX A BIPARTISAN BILL
WITH TWENTY THREE CO AUTHORS
SAID EARLIER THANK YOU FOR
BEING A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON
THE BILL WHICH INCLUDES
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS OF
PROTECTIONS INJURE CALIFORNIA
WHATEVER FACE ANOTHER CLAPS AND
IT'S UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM LIKE
WE SAW THIS LAST YEAR FROM THE
START OF COVERT NINETEEN-
PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN AND
EXPERIENCED IN OUR OFFICES- THE
MANY SHORTCOMINGS OF EDT. AS
MILLIONS WERE LAID OFF
DESPERATE SPORTY DD- EDT
STOPPED ANSWERING ITS PHONES
AND PICKED UP LESS THAN 1% OF
CALLS COMING IN. THE OF CLAIMS.
A. B. FIFTY SIX WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS BY ONE DESIGNATING
A UNIT WITH ANY D. D. TO
OVERSEE IT STREAMLINED FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION- TO
CREATING A CENTRALIZED TRACKING
TOOL THAT ALLOWS EDT TO QUICKLY
REVIEW AND STOP PAYMENT ON
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. THREE
REQUIRING EDT TO TRACK AND
ANALYZE THE INEFFICIENCIES IN
THEIR CALL CENTER TO IMPROVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND REDUCE THE
WAIT TIME CALIFORNIANS. FOR AND
REQUIRING ADD TO STOP SENDING
EMAIL WITH FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND REQUIRING EIGHTY.
TO PAY FOR IDENTITY THEFT
MONITORING- SENATORS THIS IS A
LOT OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CAME OUT OF AN AUDIT REPORT. ON
EDT AND WITH THE COLLABORATION
OF A LOT OF OUR- COLLEAGUES WE
WERE ABLE TO- TO FORMULATE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SIX TO KIND
OF ADDRESS THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT OF. THE ROUTE. THANK THE
US. IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE WHO WISHES TO
TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON THE
BILL SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LET'S SEE NONE- WE WILL LOOK TO
THE- SPILLOVER ROOM- OVERFLOW
ROOM AND WE SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE WILL HAVE SOME MODERATORS
OR ANYONE- THAT YOU CAN QUEUE
UP THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT FROM THE QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT IN- WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE WAS NO LEGAL POSITION
WITNESSES OR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO TAKE. A IN OPPOSITION
DECISION TO THE BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM HAS SEEN NONE.
OF THERE WAS NO ONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LAST TIME I
CHECKED WE SEE NO IN THERE NOW.
IN A MOTOR IT'LL COME RIGHT
BACK TO YOU AND ASK- IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT YOU CAN QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND IF
SO PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER. AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
I HAVE NO COMMENT IN Q.
RECALLING CERTAIN ONE WISH
COMMENT OR ASK QUESTIONS ON
THIS BILL CENTER WHERE. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS IS CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE J.
LACK A AND TO THE AUDIT ON EDT
WHICH WAS. THERE WAS A
CONSIDERABLE HEARING ON THIS
BILL AND ONE I'M DOING AND A
FEW OTHERS CAME OUT TO CODIFY.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND IN
DIFFERENT WAYS IT'S BASICALLY
HOW TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE BEFORE RECESSION
RATHER THINGS THERE'S ADEQUATE
PLANNING. IT AND WHILE ALL OF
US WORK TOGETHER THROUGH OUR
OFFICES TO TRY TO DEAL WITH
EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN
DISLOCATED ON THIS I THINK THIS
IS A VERY POSITIVE CONSTRUCTIVE
STEP IN AND HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT WE HAVE OVERSIGHT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AND AT THE
RIGHT TIME I'LL BE HAPPY TO
MAKE A MOTION. FOR A SERVER
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE INCIDENT
DRAWS OFF. THANK YOU- I JUST
WANT TO. LET THE AUTHOR KNOW I
WILL BE SUPPORTING BUT I DO
HAVE. AS THE ISSUE OF THE- IT.
THE CONCERNS AROUND THE
INCARCERATED AND HOW THEY WOULD
NOT BE- DISADVANTAGED OR
TARGETED BOMB IN SOME WAY-
THROUGH THIS KIND OF
LEGISLATION I KNOW THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY VARIOUS CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION SO. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ANSWER- THAT FOR
ME THANK YOU IF I MAY THROUGH
THE CHAIR- YOU KNOW THE EDT
CROSSCHECK IS ACTUALLY ANOTHER
BILL NOW WAS INITIALLY IN THE
FIRST VERSION OF THIS BILL BUT
WE CAME UP WITH A PACKAGE WITH
ALL OF THE CO AUTHORS AND
EVERYBODY KIND OF GOT A PIECE
OF THE PIE- BUT THIS BILL STILL
DOES HAVE THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR. A CROSS
CHECK WERE TO GO IN TO FIND THE
EFFICIENCIES AT IT AND MAKE
SURE THAT IS BEING AFFECTED SO
THAT PART STILL REMAINS IN THE
BILL. OKAY ANYONE ELSE OF
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THE BILL-
SEEN NONE I WILL COME BACK. TO
THE AUTHOR WHO WITH AN
OPPORTUNE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND- I THINK IT WAS CENTER
LAYERED WHO MADE THE MOTION. R.
WAS THAT CORRECT. ARE WE READY
TO. AND I CLEARLY THINK IT'S
TIME SO I MOVE IT SUNLAND
COMMOTION TO ME EARLIER THIS IS
A FIFTY. THANK YOU I'M SO
EMBARRASSED. THE MOVE FREE SHE
THAT WE APPRECIATE IT BELIEVE
ME- THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN AND
WILL COME BACK TO THE
CONSULTANT FOR THE ROLL CALL
NOW. OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
COURTESY BY THE TO THE I OR
TROUBLED BY A TRAVEL GUIDE TO
WRESTLE. PROGRESSO I LAYERED-
LAYERED I NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI. LAURA YET ANOTHER
NOW THE UNANIMOUS VOTE AND THE
BILL WAS OUT THANK YOU. SMITH
BRINGS US- OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH
REMAIN VERY WILL BE OUR FINAL
ITEM TODAY. EVERYONE SHOULD BE
CHEERING ON THE AUTHOR HERE AB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND WELCOME AND YOU
HAVE OUR FULL ATTENTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS- WAS CONSIDERING A
NAME CHANGE- EARLIER TOGETHER
OF THE ORDER BUT IT DIDN'T WORK
OUT I COULDN'T FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DO THAT ONLINE SO. BUT
ANYWAY. THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
FOR STICKING WITH ME HERE- I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO- AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
PERSONALLY BEEN EVACUATED FAR
TOO MANY TIMES. FROM MY HOME I
WILL ALWAYS BE THANKFUL FOR THE
SACRIFICE TO THE FIREFIGHTERS
WE COUNT ON TO KEEP OUR HOMES
AND OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME FIREFIGHTERS
DO GET INJURED ON THE JOB AND
WHEN THEY DO THEIR ONLY FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON RECOVERING. SO
THEY CAN RETURN TO WORK AT A
100% AND NOT WORRY ABOUT ANY
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP THAT THEIR
ENTRY MAY HAVE COST. AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
FIREFIGHTERS EMPLOYED BY CAL
FIRE TO RECEIVE 1100% OF THEIR
WAGE IF THEY SHOULD BECOME
INJURED ON THE JOB. AND ONLY UP
TO A YEAR. THE BILL WOULD BRING
CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS UP TO PAR
WITH OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- IMPORTANCE- AND
LIFEGUARDS. AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO GIVES DIGNITY AND RESPECT
TO THOSE THAT PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE FIGHTING FIRES- AND
WITH THAT I HAVE ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
PRESIDENT TIM EDWARDS WITH CAL
FIRE- TWENTY EIGHT. EIGHTY ONE.
READ THE THANK YOU AND- WE WILL
GROW BREAK TO THE SPORT.
WITNESS TIMID WORD SIR YOU MAY
PROCEED THROUGH THEIR- GOOD
EVENING COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME I KNOW IT'S LATE
EVENING I WANT TO THANK EACH
FAMILY MEMBER WAIT FOR CHAMPING
IS BECAUSE- AS HE SAID DELPHI
OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE ONE OF THE
FEW. PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT HAVE THE PROTECTION AS WE
HAVE BEEN PROVEN OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS FIRES ARE GETTING
WORSE. AND ILLNESSES AND
INJURIES ARE INCREASING BY
TAPPING THIS BILL SIGNING IT
INTO LAW IT WILL GIVE EQUALITY
TO THE FIREBIRDS OF CAL FIRE I
APPRECIATE AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
IN THE LAST TWO THIRDS ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHES TO TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION. ON THE BILL IF SO
STEP UP- SEE NONE. WHICH THE
OVER ROOM. A SENIOR THEY'RE TO
SPEAK WE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR. IN ASSAM MODERATOR
QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. AND A
PLEASE LET US KNOW NUMBER
SPEAKERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
GENERAL AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE TWO PARTIES IN THE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY ONE.
YOU'RE WELCOME NINE ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISTINA ALMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO. NINE ONE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ERIN READ REPRESENTING
PROUDLY CALIFORNIA LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE I JUST WANTED
TO BACK UP WHAT OUR PRESIDENT
SAID THIS IS LONG OVERDUE AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHICH BILL AND HIS
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE SUPPORT QUEUE. THE
MODERATOR WILL COME UP TO THE
OPPOSITION SO I'M GO THROUGH
THEIR PROCESS NOW WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS SIR
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH IS TO TAKE IN
OPPOSITION POSITION ON THE
BILL. SEEN NONE OF WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE TO TESTIFY- IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. AND SO WE'LL ASK
YOU ONE LAST TIME TONIGHT'S
MODERATOR- IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THIS TIME TO AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND UNDER.
WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
OKAY THERE'S NO ONE NINE THIRTY
RIGHT MODERATOR- SO WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE WILL CHECK WITH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES ANYBODY HAVE
ANYTHING ON THIS BILL THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO. COMMENT ON FOR
ED I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. MOVE
THE BILL COMING FROM SENATOR
LAYERED AND ON BEFORE WE- MOVE
ON THE BILL WE'RE GONNA GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. UP JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO THE MOTION IS BY SENATOR
LAYERED. MASA CONSULTANT TO
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE NO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY HI.
WHERE DOES THE AYE OR TROUBLED
BY A TRAVEL GUIDE TO WRESTLE.
THE REST SO I LAYERED. LAYERED
I NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE RIGHT-
THAT IS UNANIMOUS VOTE ALL
RIGHT THE BILL ITSELF THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TONIGHT A
CRUCIATE IS. PROJECTING THANK
YOU TO ALL THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY BUT FOR
SOME REASON YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO
GET THROUGH OR TESTIFY YOU CAN
SUBMIT ANY COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING- TO THE
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE AS YOU HEARD SOME
OF THESE BILLS ARE DOUBLE
REFERRED TO YOUR COMMENTS CAN
BE. MADE PART OF THE RECORD FOR
THE NEXT COMMITTEE WHEN THAT'S
THE CASE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE HELP- IMPATIENCE TONIGHT
HELP FROM OUR STAFF. EXCELLENT
WORK BY THE MODERATOR OF THE
SENATE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU FOR.